SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO, GIL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALLY DODD. DURAZO.
EGGMAN GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD LIMON.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO CIERTO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG WAHAB. WIENER.
WILK MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS.
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY. PLEASE RISE. WE'LL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. AFTER WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. SENATOR
EGGMAN. AS STUDENTS AND TEACHERS
BEGIN ANOTHER SCHOOL YEAR, AND
AS ALL OF US CONTINUE TO BE
EDUCATED EVERY DAY, LET US PRAY
THAT WE WILL NEVER THROW IN THE
TOWEL WHEN SITUATIONS BECOME
DIFFICULT, AS ILLUSTRATED IN
THIS POEM BY SISTER PAT RYAN. I
NEARLY THREW IN THE TOWEL. IT
WAS MAY, MY FIRST YEAR TEACHING.
AFTER ALGEBRA CLASS, CARLENE
WHISPERED IN MY EAR, SISTER,
WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO LEARN WHAT
X IS? OH, CARLENE, SO MANY YEARS
LATER, I CANNOT TELL YOU A LOT
MORE ABOUT X. IT ONLY IT NOT
ONLY MARKS THE SPOT, IT
SYMBOLIZES EVERY UNKNOWN, EVERY
MYSTERY. IT'S A LETTER THAT
EVERYONE IS LOOKING FOR. I'VE
LEARNED SO MUCH SINCE YOU
STUNNED ME WITH THAT QUESTION.
MY ANSWER RIGHT NOW WOULD BE
NEVER. WE ARE NEVER GOING TO
LEARN WHAT X IS. IT IS A
NAMELESS ESSENCE OF THE ETERNAL
SEARCH, THE MAGNET PULLING THE
EVOLUTIONARY PROCESS. IT IS
TOTALLY AVAILABLE AND OPEN TO
ANY BRAIN THAT NEEDS A MARKER TO
HOLD ON TO THE INFINITE REALITY
PASSING THROUGH. WE ARE NEVER
GOING TO LEARN WHAT X IS, BUT WE
WILL NEVER STOP TRYING. AMEN
MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
ALL RIGHT. BEFORE WE MOVE TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR, WE HAVE
A SPECIAL ANNOUNCEMENT. LET'S
ALL GIVE A CALIFORNIA SENATE
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO NONE OTHER
THAN SENATOR NANCY SKINNER.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY. WISH YOU ANOTHER
21. HAPPY YEARS. GO RIGHT ON.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
MEMBERS. AT THIS TIME, WE WILL
BEGIN WITH OUR 2024 SENATE
FELLOW PRESENTATION. OUR
PRESIDENT PRO TEM WILL GET US
STARTED WITH HIS REMARKS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU. I'M GOING TO
JUST TAKE A MOMENT. COLLEAGUES,
I RISE TODAY TO MARK THE END OF
A JOURNEY AND THE BEGINNING OF A
BRIGHT NEW FUTURE. AS WE NEAR
THE FINAL STAGE OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION, WE NEED TO
TAKE A MOMENT AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THE 2024 COHORT OF SENATE
FELLOWS. THESE ACCOMPLISHED
YOUNG LEADERS ARE TRULY SOME OF
THE GOLDEN STATE'S BEST AND
BRIGHTEST. THIS YEAR'S FELLOWS
COME FROM UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES. FROM EVERY CORNER OF
THIS GREAT STATE. CSU'S, UC'S
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS, AND EVEN
THE UNIVERSITY OF RHODE ISLAND,
WHERE CECILIA IS A PROUD RHODY
RAM. NOW, LET ME BE CLEAR. IT IS
NOT EASY TO BECOME A SENATE
FELLOW. THESE FOLKS MADE IT
THROUGH A HIGHLY SELECTIVE
PROCESS. IN FACT, 130 130
INDIVIDUALS APPLIED FOR THIS
DISTINGUISHED COHORT. ONLY 18
MADE THE CUT. THESE LEADERS HERE
TODAY SET THEMSELVES APART FROM
THE REST, SHOWING THAT THEY ARE
TENACIOUS. THEY ARE SMART,
DILIGENT, AND KNOW HOW TO
DELIVER FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND FOR THE PAST 11
MONTHS THEY HAVE RUN RAGGED,
THEY'VE RUN RAGGED. STAFF AND
BILLS AND COMMITTEES, WRITING,
ANALYSIS AND FLOOR MARKS AND
PRETTY MUCH BEING EVERYWHERE,
ALL AT ONCE IN TWO DIFFERENT
BUILDINGS. IT'S SOMETHING TO
ADMIRE. AND THIS INSTITUTION IN
OUR STATE IS STRONGER BECAUSE OF
THEIR HARD WORK AND BECAUSE OF
THEIR LEADERSHIP. ON A PERSONAL
NOTE, CHRIS NIELSEN, WHO I GET
TO WORK WITH EVERY DAY IN OUR
OFFICE NOW, A SENIOR POLICY
ADVISOR, STARTED OUT AS A FELLOW
NEARLY A DECADE AGO. SO THERE'S
NO DOUBT IN MY MIND WE ARE IN
THE COMPANY OF LEADERSHIP HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
THESE FELLOWS. WE ARE IN THE
COMPANY OF LEADERS IN THE STATE
SENATE. I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE
ARE IMMENSELY PROUD, NO MATTER
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT OR A
REPUBLICAN. WE ARE IMMENSELY
PROUD OF THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE HERE IN THE CAPITOL. AND ON
BEHALF OF THIS ESTEEMED BODY,
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
FOR HELPING US SHAPE POLICY FOR
NEARLY 40 MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, FROM THE
STATE SENATE, I WANT TO HEAR YOU
LOUD AND PROUD. LET'S GIVE IT UP
FOR THE 2024 COHORT OF SENATE
FELLOWS. LET'S GO.
SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES OF THE
SENATE. IF IT WORKS FOR FOLKS,
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO KICK OFF
OUR RECOGNITION OF THE 2024
COHORT COLLEAGUES.
UNFORTUNATELY, SENATOR UMBERG,
WHO WANTED TO BE HERE TODAY,
COULD NOT. HE IS OUT FOR FAMILY
BUSINESS. AND I WANTED TO TAKE A
MOMENT AND ASSIST IN RECOGNIZING
HIS AMAZING FELLOW MOUFIDA ASSAF
MOUFIDA IS A PALESTINIAN
AMERICAN WHO LIVED IN JORDAN AT
A YOUNG AGE. IN ADDITION TO
LIVING IN BOTH NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, SHE
GRADUATED FROM UC RIVERSIDE,
WHERE SHE WAS STUDENT BODY
PRESIDENT. HER STRONG SENSE OF
JUSTICE AND DETERMINATION HAS
MADE HER AN INVALUABLE ASSET AND
A TEAM MEMBER TO SENATOR UMBERG,
WHERE SHE HAS EXCELLED IN ALL OF
HER FOCUS AREAS. MOUFIDA IS
ALREADY READY TO JUMP AT ANY
CHANCE TO HELP, AND SHE HAS
WORKED ON A PLETHORA OF TOUGH
BILLS, INCLUDING ONES RELATED TO
HOUSING, SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT, AS WELL AS CARE CORP.
SHE SEAMLESSLY EMBEDDED HERSELF
INTO THE OFFICE OF SENATOR
UMBERG HER ENTIRE HIS ENTIRE
TEAM LOVES WHAT SHE DOES, AND
SHE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
MANY YEARS TO COME. CAN WE
PLEASE GIVE HER A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE AND SAY THANK YOU TO
YOUR TREMENDOUS WORK, TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE AND TO
SENATOR UMBERG.
MR. LAMONE, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU. OUR OFFICE IS TRULY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE AILEEN AMADOR
AS A FELLOW ON TÌM LIMÓN,
ORIGINALLY FROM TORREON,
COAHUILA, MEXICO, AILEEN MOVED
TO THE US AT THE AGE OF 16. SHE
LATER ATTENDED UC SANTA CRUZ,
WHERE SHE EARNED HER BACHELOR'S
OF ARTS IN LEGAL STUDIES AND A
MINOR IN GLOBAL INFORMATION AND
SOCIAL ENTERPRISE STUDIES. OVER
THE PAST YEAR, AILEEN HAS SHOWN
REMARKABLE GROWTH AND A STRONG
COMMITMENT TO LEARNING,
CONSISTENTLY ASKING INSIGHTFUL
QUESTIONS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ISSUES. HER POSITIVE
ATTITUDE HAS REALLY ENRICHED OUR
OFFICE AND SHE CONSTANTLY
DEMONSTRATES GREAT ENTHUSIASM,
WHETHER ON HER WORK, WHEN SHE'S
INTRODUCING BILLS OR WHETHER
SHE'S INTRODUCING US TO CAMELIA
OR THE COLD BREWS OR CELSIUS
FROM DEMONSTRATING AN INTEREST
IN TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO
LEADING SOME OF OUR MOST
CHALLENGING LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR, AILEEN HAS EXCELLED IN A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME. HER
BACKGROUND AS AN IMMIGRANT FROM
MEXICO, AS A TEENAGER WHO CAME
TO THIS COUNTRY FULL OF
INSPIRATION, ALSO INSPIRES ALL
OF US. AILEEN EXEMPLIFIES THE
BEST OF THE CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCE, AND WE ARE FORTUNATE
TO HAVE HER ON OUR TEAM. WE ARE
DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE OF HER WORK
ON BEHALF OF SENATE DISTRICT 19
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WATCHING HER SUCCEED IN THE
YEARS TO COME. CONGRATULATIONS,
AILEEN.
SENATOR HURTADO. I'M SORRY. I'M
SORRY. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THIS YEAR WE HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF HAVING CARMEN ALLEN PLACED IN
OUR OFFICE AS OUR SENATE FELLOW.
CARMEN IS A PROUD SACRAMENTO
NATIVE AND FIRST GENERATION
LATINA COLLEGE STUDENT WHO
ATTENDED UC BERKELEY, WHERE SHE
EARNED HER BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
LEGAL STUDIES AND PUBLIC POLICY.
CARMEN COMES FROM A HARD WORKING
MEXICAN AMERICAN FAMILY AND
ATTRIBUTES TO HER WORKING CLASS
UPBRINGING AS THE LARGEST
MOTIVATOR IN HER EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE HER COMMUNITY. CARMEN
HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS ASSET TO
OUR OFFICE THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
AND TACKLED COMPLEX ISSUES WHILE
ANALYZING LEGISLATION ON THE
SENATE JUDICIARY, PUBLIC SAFETY,
HOUSING, TRANSPORTATION AND
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE. IN
ADDITION, CARMEN HAS MADE SURE
TO CONTRIBUTE TO SENATE DISTRICT
16 IN VARIOUS WAYS. ONE OF THEM
IS THROUGH HER WORK ON SENATE
BILL 1183, SENATE BILL 1183 WILL
EXPAND THE ADMISSION CRITERIA
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
STUDENTS FROM MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED REGIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. PRESENTLY, THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS WITNESSING A
MASSIVE NURSING SHORTAGE, AND
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND MANY
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE ACROSS
THE STATE, INCLUDING THOSE IN
THE SACRAMENTO REGION, WITH
INCREASED LOCALLY TRAINED
SKILLED NURSES POST FELLOWSHIP.
I KNOW CARMEN WILL CONTINUE TO
MAKE A POSITIVE IMPACT IN THE
LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. CARMEN ASPIRES TO
ATTEND LAW SCHOOL SO THAT SHE
CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY WITHIN
CALIFORNIA AND AROUND THE
NATION. PRESENTLY, CARMEN WORKS
WITH A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION IN SACRAMENTO,
MIRACLE UNIVERSITY, WHICH
PROVIDES HIGH SCHOOL YOUTH IN
SACRAMENTO WITH COLLEGE ACCESS
SERVICES AND ENSURES THEIR
VOICES ARE HEARD IN THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS. I KNOW CARMEN
WILL CONTINUE HER WORK WITH THIS
ORGANIZATION TO ENSURE THAT HER
COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO MAKE
POSITIVE PROGRESS, AND MANY
OTHER GREAT THINGS AROUND THE
NATION. CONGRATULATIONS, CARMEN.
SENATOR WIENER Þ. SENATOR WAHAB,
YOU'RE NEXT. I'M SORRY. THANK
YOU, TO THE SENATE, I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT OUR NEXT FELLOW IS
ACTUALLY A GREAT YOUNG MAN. IN
FACT, HE TAKES JOKES AND GIVES
JOKES JUST AS BEST AS THE REST
OF US. AND I REALLY ENJOY MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH HIM. HE IS
THE SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE FELLOW, AND I JUST
JOKED WITH HIM. I SAID, I WANT
TO MAKE SURE I GET YOUR NAME
RIGHT. IT'S SO DIFFICULT FOR ME
TO SAY SO. OUR NEXT FELLOW IS
ACTUALLY JOHN DUNCAN AND YOU
KNOW, HE TOLD ME THE H IS
SILENT. SO I JUST REALLY WANT TO
GIVE KUDOS TO JOHN. THE WORK
THAT HE DID THIS YEAR ON SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY IS EXTREMELY HARD.
THERE'S A LOT OF SENSITIVE
ISSUES, HE ACTUALLY STAFFED
SEVERAL BILLS AND MADE SURE THAT
HIS ANALYSIS AND EVERYTHING WAS
CORRECT. JOHN IS A LOCAL. HE
ACTUALLY GREW UP IN WEST
SACRAMENTO AND HE ATTENDED SAINT
MARY'S COLLEGE IN MORAGA, WHERE
HE GRADUATED IN 2023. JOHN HAS
BEEN A GREAT ASSET TO THE
COMMITTEE. HE'S ACTUALLY VERY
SMART, FLEXIBLE, EASYGOING AND
ALWAYS VOLUNTEERS TO HELP A
LITTLE BIT MORE IN FACT, HE
WANTED TO VOLUNTEER WITH OUR
OFFICE JUST TO CARRY SOME OF THE
BILLS THAT WE WANTED TO DO.
ANYONE THAT KNOWS HIM KNOWS HE'S
ALWAYS ARMED WITH A DAD JOKE,
AND TO PUT A SMILE ON YOUR FACE
OR TO MAKE YOU KIND OF GROAN, OR
YOU HAD A TOUGH DAY. SO HE'S A
VERY, VERY GOOD GUY. HE ANALYZED
A LOT OF BILLS ON A VARIETY OF
SUBJECTS, INCLUDING FROM THE
FEATHER ALERTS TO SHOOTING RANGE
TARGETS TO BAN BOOKS IN PRISON
AND VOTING ON PRIVATE JAILS. BUT
HE'S ALSO, AGAIN, VERY MUCH
WILLING TO HELP EVERYBODY. HE
GLADLY BROUGHT BILLS AND
PAPERWORK TO THE DESK WHEN THE
COMMITTEE WAS DOWN, AND
ASSISTANT AND VOLUNTEERED FOR
OTHER TASKS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING WHAT JOHN'S FUTURE HOLDS
FOR HIM, AND WE KNOW THAT HE'S
GOING TO BE A GREAT ASSET TO ANY
OFFICE THAT ABSORBS HIM, AND
AGAIN, WE LOOK VERY MUCH FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING HIM. AND THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT THE FELLOWSHIP IS
ABOUT. IT'S ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE
GETTING A TASTE FOR POLICYMAKING
AND WHAT THIS BUILDING IS REALLY
ABOUT. AND IT'S ABOUT SERVING
PEOPLE. AND JOHN DOES THAT EVERY
DAY. SO PLEASE CONGRATULATE
JOHN. THANK YOU.
SENATOR WIENER, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT,
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO RECOGNIZE
RASHIDA GOWDY, WHO, WE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF HOSTING IN OUR
OFFICE AS A FELLOW, THIS YEAR,
ROTHECA WAS BORN IN WALNUT CREEK
AND RAISED IN DANVILLE AS THE
DAUGHTER OF TWO IMMIGRANTS AND
THE OLDEST OF TWO. HER
UPBRINGING INSTILLED IN HER A
PASSION FOR PUBLIC SERVICE. SHE
FIRST WANTED TO BE A CAPITAL
FELLOW AFTER INTERNING IN
SENATOR SKINNER'S, DISTRICT
OFFICE AS A 16 YEAR OLD IN HIGH
SCHOOL, SHE THEN ATTENDED UC
DAVIS, WHERE SHE MAJORED IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE, PUBLIC
SERVICE WITH A MINOR IN
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY, ANALYST
AND ANALYSIS, AND PLANNING,
WHILE AT UC DAVIS, SHE SERVED AS
THE SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM AND
LATER AS STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT,
SHE STAFF IS STAFFING, FOUR OF
MY MOST CHALLENGING BILLS. I DO
OCCASIONALLY DO A CHALLENGING
BILL, AND SHE'S STAFFING FOR
THEM THIS YEAR. TWO RESOLUTIONS.
AND WHEN I WAS SITTING ON THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, SHE WAS MY
SOLE STAFFER. STAFFING ME ON
THAT VERY, VERY CHALLENGING
COMMITTEE, SHE HAS FIT RIGHT IN
WITH OUR HARD WORKING, VERY FUN
OFFICE, INCLUDING OUR
COMPETITION WITH SENATOR
SKINNER'S OFFICE AROUND WHO CAN
DECORATE OUR DOORS THE MOST
AGGRESSIVELY, AND SHE'S JUST
BEEN A WONDERFUL ADDITION TO OUR
TEAM, RADHIKA IS DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO PUBLIC SERVICE.
SHE'S INCREDIBLY TALENTED, AND I
KNOW SHE HAS A VERY, VERY BRIGHT
AND PROMISING FUTURE AHEAD.
WHERE SHE ULTIMATELY INTENDS TO
GO TO LAW SCHOOL. BUT I HOPE SHE
PUTS SOME MORE TIME IN IN THIS
BUILDING BECAUSE SHE'S A TRUE
ASSET, AS TO USE A WORD THAT
RADHIKA LIKES TO USE, SHE HAS
BEEN A SLEIGH, SO PLEASE HELP ME
IN THANKING HER FOR HER SERVICE
TO THE SENATE, TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND TO THE PEOPLE OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND NORTHERN SAN
MATEO COUNTY.
CONGRATULATIONS. WE NEXT WANT TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR BRADFORD AT
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
SENATOR BRADFORD, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND IT'S WITH GREAT
HONOR AND PRIDE THAT I HAVE THE
PLEASURE TO RECOGNIZE A YOUNG
MAN WHO HAS SPENT THE LAST 11
MONTHS AT MY OFFICE AS A FELLOW
AND THAT'S NONE OTHER THAN
VINCENT NGUYEN. VINCENT IS FROM
THE CITY OF EL MONTE, AND
GRADUATED FROM CAL STATE
FULLERTON WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN PUBLIC ADMINISTRATION
FROM THE FIRST DAY. VINCENT WAS
EAGER TO GET TO WORK IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE. HIS
INSIGHTFUL QUESTIONS REGARDING
BOTH THE POLICY AND PROCEDURAL
ASPECTS OF THE JOB KEPT US ALL
ON OUR TOES AND LED TO A GREATER
OVERALL UNDERSTANDING OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. VINCENT'S
WORK HAS PROVED INVALUABLE TO
OUR LEGISLATIVE AND DISTRICT
STAFF. HE APPROACHED EVERY TASK
ASSIGNED TO HIM WITH ENTHUSIASM
AND CONFIDENCE, PROFESSIONAL AND
EXTREMELY PERSONABLE, VINCENT
HAS BEEN A CONSTANT SOURCE OF
OPTIMISM, HUMOR, AND EVEN HUMOR
DURING SOME OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT TIMES, AND HE'S ALWAYS
HAD A WAY TO COME INTO MY OFFICE
AND LET HIS HAIR DOWN TO PROVE
THAT HE HAD MORE HAIR THAN ME.
MY OFFICE LEARNED MUCH ABOUT
VINCENT'S CULTURE AND HOMETOWN.
HE WAS A COMPETITIVE SWIMMER, I
DIDN'T KNOW THIS ELECTRIC DANCE
MUSIC. HE DIDN'T SHARE THAT WITH
ME. AND WE ALSO LEARNED THAT THE
MAN LOVES TO EAT. HE IS THE
OFFICIAL CAUCUS LUNCH CAUCUS
CHAIR FOR THE FELLOWS, AND HE IS
EITHER A RECYCLER OR HE LOVES
TARGET BECAUSE HE BROUGHT HIS
FOOD IN EVERY DAY AND A TARGET
BAG. HE STABBED MULTIPLE COMPLEX
BILLS ACROSS SEVERAL ISSUES
AREAS, INCLUDING CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FROM HARMFUL
OVERDRAFT FEES, HOMEOWNER'S
ASSISTANCE FOR DESCENDANTS OF
ENSLAVED PEOPLE, AND PROHIBITING
LAW ENFORCEMENT, USE OF ETHNIC
SHOOTING TARGETS. VINCENT
ENTHUSIASTICALLY TOOK OVER THE
ROLE OF STAFFING ME ON SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE,
PROVIDING ANALYSIS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON SOME OF THE
MOST DIFFICULT BILLS. THIS
SESSION. I'M CONFIDENT THAT HE
HAS THE INTELLIGENCE, THE WORK
ETHIC AND COMMUNICATION SKILLS
TO THRIVE IN ANY ENDEAVOR THAT
HE CHOOSES TO PURSUE IN THE
FUTURE. VINCENT, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO NOT ONLY THE
35TH SENATE DISTRICT, BUT TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
CONGRATULATIONS WE WOULD LIKE TO
NEXT RECOGNIZE SENATOR CIERTO AT
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
SENATOR CIERTO THANK YOU MR.
PRESIDENT, MEMBERS TODAY I'M
HERE AND I AM HONORED TO PRESENT
AND INTRODUCE MY SENATE FELLOW,
CHRISTIAN LOPEZ. I'D FIRST LIKE
TO NOTE THAT WHILE I'M PROUD TO
SAY THAT MY CAPITOL LEGISLATIVE
TEAM IS COMPRISED ENTIRELY OF
PAST FELLOWS, CHRISTIAN ALSO HAS
THE SPECIAL HONOR OF COMING FROM
OUR DISTRICT, HAILING FROM THE
CITY OF NORCO, WHICH IS ALSO
KNOWN AS HORSETOWN USA. HE
GRADUATED MAGNA LAUDE FROM CAL
BAPTIST UNIVERSITY WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE. CHRISTIAN WAS ALSO THE
DEBATE CHAMPION FOR HIS DEBATE
LEAGUE, AND WE FOUND OUT HOW
GOOD OF A DEBATER HE IS THIS
YEAR, TAKING ON THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF STAFFING ME
ON THE COMMITTEES OF NATURAL
RESOURCES AND TRANSPORTATION,
CHRISTIAN HAS TAKEN ON THE HEAVY
BILLS FROM THOSE COMMITTEES AND
HAS PROVIDED ME WITH AMAZING
ANALYSIS AND SUPPORT. THIS IS ON
TOP OF THE FOUR BILLS HE TOOK
LEAD ON, ONE OF WHICH HAS
ALREADY BEEN SIGNED INTO LAW BY
THE GOVERNOR. HIS RESEARCH,
PROBLEM SOLVING AND PUBLIC
SERVICE MINDSET HAVE ALSO HELPED
IN HIS COVERAGE OF OUR STAFFING.
MANY OTHER SUBJECTS IN OUR
OFFICE LIKE LABOR, HUMAN
SERVICES AND EDUCATION. HE HAS
BROUGHT HIS SMILE, HIS AMAZING
AMOUNT OF ENERGY AND A GREAT
WORK ETHIC TO OUR TEAM.
CHRISTIAN CONSTANTLY SEEKS TO
SERVE NOT JUST OUR TEAM, BUT THE
OFFICE AND OUR OFFICE, BUT HIS
OWN COMMUNITY AND OUR 32ND
SENATE DISTRICT. AND I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT HE HAS
ACCEPTED AN OFFER TO BECOME A
FULL TIME LEGISLATIVE AIDE FOR
OUR CAPITOL OFFICE. SO WE ARE SO
HAPPY TO WELCOME HIM TO OUR TEAM.
SO IT IS WITH GREAT PLEASURE AND
HONOR THAT WE PRESENT HIM WITH
THIS RESOLUTION AND RECOGNIZE
HIS ACCOMPLISHMENT IN THE
CAPITOL'S CAPITAL FELLOWS
PROGRAM.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND GOOD AFTERNOON,
MEMBERS. I RISE TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE THE WORK OF THIS
YEAR'S SENATE FELLOWSHIP COHORT,
AS WELL AS OUR AMAZING FELLOW,
KENYA MARIE MAHONEY. SHE'S
JOINED HERE TODAY BY HER
PARENTS, KEN AND MARIE, WHO ARE
IN THE GALLERY. AND I WANT TO
THANK THEM FOR THEIR WORK OF
INSTILLING IN KENYA THE VALUES
OF EQUITY, JUSTICE AND A STRONG
WORK ETHIC, PART OF THIS IS A
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
AND KENYA WAS ONE OF THOSE WAS A
FELLOW WHO WAS THE FIRST ONE IN
THE OFFICE, THE LAST ONE OUT OF
THE OFFICE, THE FIRST ONE TO
RESPOND TO A TEXT TO AN EMAIL.
SHE WAS OUR PINCH HITTER THIS
SESSION, ORIGINALLY FROM THE BAY
AREA, KENYA, ATTENDED POMONA
COLLEGE IN CLAREMONT,
CALIFORNIA, WHERE SHE STUDIED
PUBLIC POLICY AND DISCOVERED HER
PASSION FOR LOCAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENT. AND KENYA IS ALSO A
FIGHTER. SHE NOT ONLY HAS A
PASSION, BUT SHE STUDIES STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND SHE
WILL FIGHT YOU WITH FACTS. TO
SAY THIS IS A WAY THAT WE CAN
MOVE THIS BILL. AND SHE DID THAT
ON OUR DIVERSION BILL. SHE
HANDLED AND LED ON MY SB 1446,
ONE OF OUR MOST PUBLIC BILLS,
AND CONTROVERSIAL BILLS, AND SHE
ALSO STAFFED ME ON THE
REPARATIONS PACKAGE. AND AS A
STAFFER FOR THE CAUCUS, KENYA
WAS A JACK OF ALL TRADES, AND
SHE MASTERED THEM ALL. BEYOND
MANAGING LEGISLATION, KENYA HAS
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO JUMP IN
ON VARIOUS PROJECTS, INCLUDING
COMMUNITY EVENTS WHERE SHE
ROLLED UP HER SLEEVES AND EVEN
CAME DOWN TO THE DISTRICT TO
SUPPORT. KENYA HAS PLAYED A
PIVOTAL ROLE IN OUR LEGISLATIVE
TEAM, NAVIGATING AND NEGOTIATING
AND RESEARCHING ISSUES ON HEALTH
CARE AND LABOR AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE, INTERSECTIONALITY, TO
NAME A FEW. KENYA ALSO, ALONG
WITH THE REST OF THIS AMAZING
COHORT, WHICH I HAD THE HONOR TO
HAVE LUNCH WITH, DURING THEIR
YEAR AND THEY ALL HAD SO MANY
AMAZING QUESTIONS AND REALLY
REPRESENTED THE ENERGY THAT WE
SO NEED IN THIS CHAMBER. BUT
KENYA IN PARTICULAR JUST
PROVIDED A DAY TO DAY
PERSPECTIVE THAT REALLY
ENERGIZED AND MOTIVATED ME ON
DAYS WHEN IT WAS JUST FRANKLY,
TOUGH, OUR SENATE FELLOWS WHO
COME FROM ACROSS CALIFORNIA WITH
DIFFERING POLITICAL AND
IDEOLOGICAL VIEWS, DO IN FACT
REPRESENT THE FUTURE OF THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THEY HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR OFFICE EVERY
SINGLE DAY. WE WANT TO THANK
KENYA FOR ALL AND ALL OF THE
FELLOWS FOR THEIR AMAZING WORK,
FOR WHAT THEY BRING TO THE
LEGISLATURE EACH AND EVERY DAY.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, WHAT KENYA
HAS PROVIDED US AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HER FOR
MANY, MANY, MANY, MANY, MANY
MORE YEARS TO COME. THANK YOU.
NEXT UP, SENATOR OCHOA BOGH.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. TODAY
I HAVE THE, Ó BORN AND RAISED
INTO LARRY LINDSEY MENDOZA
GRADUATED FROM THE FRESNO STATE
WITH DEGREES IN AGRICULTURAL
BUSINESS AND POLITICAL SCIENCE.
LINDSEY HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
PLEASURE TO HAVE TO HAVE YOU IN
MY OFFICE. I ALWAYS ENJOY SEEING
THE SENATE THROUGH THE EYES OF
OUR FELLOWS. THEY ARE EAGER,
EXCITED TO EXPERIENCE EVERY PART
OF OUR WORK. AND YOU WERE NO
EXCEPTION. YOU WERE ALWAYS
WILLING TO JUMP IN AND ATTEND
EVENTS WITH ME. YOU SUPPORTED
YOUR TEAMMATES AND WERE GRACIOUS
WITH EVERYONE WHO CAME INTO THE
OFFICE. SHE TOOK COPIOUS NOTES
AND RELAYED THE INFO ACCURATELY,
GIVING OBJECTIVE FEEDBACK, WHICH
I ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATED. AND I
DO HAVE TO INSERT IN HERE THAT
LINDSEY, I'VE BEEN HERE. THIS IS
MY FOURTH YEAR, AND I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO BE BLESSED WITH THREE
INTERNS ALL, SMART, BRIGHT,
KIND, AND VERY STYLISH WOMEN.
AND I DO HAVE TO NOTE THAT
LINDSEY WAS NO EXCEPTION TO THIS
STYLE. VERY MUCH ALWAYS COMING
ON POINT TO OUR OFFICE AND MANY
PROBABLY NOTICED HER TALL WHITE
BOOTS. ALWAYS IN STYLE HERE. AND
I HAVE TO MENTION THAT BECAUSE
IT REALLY IS A PLEASURE TO HAVE
A YOUNG WOMEN WHO ACTUALLY BRING
FORTH A LEVEL OF DECORUM AND
PROFESSIONALISM TO THE OFFICE.
AND OF COURSE, LINDSEY WAS A
BEAUTIFUL EXAMPLE OF THAT. BUT
WITH THAT, I ALSO WANT TO TAKE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO THANK HER
PARENTS FOR RAISING SUCH A FINE
YOUNG WOMAN. OUR CHILDREN ARE
NOT RAISED BY THEMSELVES, AND IT
REALLY DOES TAKE AN INCREDIBLE
PARTNERSHIP WITH PARENTS AND
FAMILY TO HELP SUPPORT THAT. AND
THEY HAVE MADE AN INCREDIBLE,
INCREDIBLE IMPRESSION. AND WE'RE
BLESSED TO HAVE HER WITH US, IT
IS CLEAR YOU HAVE AN INCREDIBLY
BRIGHT FUTURE AHEAD OF YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE JOY AND
LAUGHTER YOU BROUGHT TO THE
OFFICE AND STYLE, AND WE'RE
REALLY GOING TO MISS YOU,
LINDSEY. THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU.
NEXT UP, WE HAVE SENATOR
CABALLERO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, TODAY, I
HAVE THE DISTINCT HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE SENATE FELLOW JOSE
RUIZ BENITEZ FOR HIS SERVICE AND
CONTRIBUTION TO THE 14TH SENATE
DISTRICT. JOSE RUIZ BENITEZ
GRADUATED FROM CHICO STATE
UNIVERSITY WITH A BA IN
ECONOMICS AND IS A PROUD ALUMNUS
OF SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE AND A
NATIVE OF SACRAMENTO. HE'S BEEN
A TREMENDOUS ASSET IN OUR OFFICE
AND AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT PART
OF OUR TEAM. HIS DEDICATION TO
LEARNING AND UNDERSTANDING THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS HELPED HIM
TO BECOME AN ESSENTIAL TEAM
MEMBER. DURING HIS TIME IN THE
OFFICE, JOSE STAFF SEVERAL BILLS
AND ANALYZED AN ARRAY OF COMPLEX
ISSUES IN HEALTH, EDUCATION AND
JUDICIARY. HE HAS A CAPACITY TO
LEARN DIFFICULT ISSUES IN A
SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME, AND ONE OF
HIS MOST NOTABLE ACHIEVEMENTS IS
THE WORK HE DID ON MY SEISMIC
SAFETY LEGISLATION. NOT AN EASY
TOPIC. HE PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE
IN ADVANCING THIS BILL THROUGH
HIS RESEARCH, ATTENTION TO
DETAIL AND COLLABORATION WITH
JOINT AND COAUTHORS, ALONG WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. IN ADDITION, JOSE
HAS PERFORMED REMARKABLE WORK
LEARNING HOW TO STAFF COMMITTEES
AND QUICKLY BRIEF ON THOSE
ISSUES. HIS DEDICATION,
RELIABILITY, AND COMMUNICATION
SKILLS ARE SOME OF HIS
ATTRIBUTES WHICH CONTRIBUTED TO
HIS SUCCESS AND WILL ENSURE HIS
LONG TERM SUCCESS BEYOND HIS
LEGISLATIVE WORK. JOSE'S
CONTRIBUTION TO OUR OFFICE HAS
BEEN INVALUABLE. OUR OFFICE
WOULD NOT BE THE SAME WITHOUT
JOSE'S SMILE AND SENSE OF HUMOR,
WHICH OFTEN LEADS LEAVES US
WONDERING IF THE ROOM IS
LAUGHING WITH HIM OR AT HIM. AND
LET'S NOT FORGET HIS RANDOM
BURSTS OF SINGING, WHICH ENSURE
THAT THE DOOR TO MY OFFICE IS
REGULARLY CLOSED. AND YET IT IS
ALL BROUGHT A UNIQUE ENERGY TO
OUR DAILY ROUTINES. HØI JOSE
ESTÁ ACOMPANADO POR SUS PADRES
EL SENOR JOSE RUIZ GÓMEZ Y LA
SENORA LAURA RUIZ BENITEZ MUCHAS
GRACIAS A SUS PADRES POR EL
EXCELENTE TRABAJO CREANDO UN
JOVEN CON BUENOS VALORES Y UNA
ÉTICA EXCEPTIONAL. I'M
RECOGNIZING HIS PARENTS FOR
RAISING SUCH A, INCREDIBLY
EXCEPTIONAL, EXCEPTIONAL YOUNG
MAN. THANK YOU, JOSE RUIZ
BENITEZ, FOR YOUR EXCELLENT
STAFF WORK AND YOUR DEDICATED
SERVICE TO THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, TO THE DISTRICT 14.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR PORTANTINO.
MR. PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO RISE TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE MOHAMMAD SALMAN, THE
DEDICATED SENATE FELLOW IN
SENATOR NEWMAN'S OFFICE, WHO
ALSO SPENT TIME AS A SAC
SEMESTER INTERN IN MY OFFICE.
MOHAMMAD IS ORIGINALLY FROM
FREMONT, BUT HIS LIFE JOURNEY
HAS TAKEN HIM ACROSS THE COUNTRY
TO INDIANA, GEORGIA, ILLINOIS,
AND MOST RECENTLY TO ELK GROVE.
MOHAMMED GRADUATED FROM
SACRAMENTO STATE WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE. SENATOR NEWMAN SHARED
THAT OVER THE COURSE OF HIS
FELLOWSHIP, MOHAMMAD HAS
DEMONSTRATED AN IMPRESSIVE
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE AND
AN ADMIRABLE INTEREST IN PUBLIC
POLICY. AS A KEY MEMBER OF
SENATOR NEWMAN'S POLICY TEAM,
MOHAMMED'S FOCUS HAS BEEN IN THE
AREAS OF JUDICIARY, PUBLIC
SAFETY, INSURANCE AND MILITARY
AND VETERANS AFFAIRS. HE HAS
PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN STAFFING
SIX BILLS, INCLUDING SB 1080,
WHICH SOUGHT TO ENSURE HALAL AND
KOSHER FOOD OPTIONS IN SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE TO HAVE SUCH
SIZABLE COHORTS OF STUDENTS
OBSERVING RELIGIOUS DIETARY
PRACTICES. A PROJECT HE
CONSIDERS THE HIGHLIGHT OF HIS
FELLOWSHIP IN ADDITION TO HIS
LEGISLATIVE WORK, FOR A TIME,
MOHAMMAD ALSO BRAVELY TOOK ON
THE ROLE OF INTERIM SCHEDULER.
WE ALL KNOW HOW DIFFICULT THAT
JOB IS. IMAGINE BEING A FELLOW
BEING ASKED TO DO POLICY AND
SCHEDULING AND THOUGH WE AND HE
LEARNED THAT SCHEDULING JUST
MIGHT NOT BE HIS TRUE FINAL
CALLING, HIS EFFORTS IN THIS
DEMANDING POSITION PROVED JUST
HOW EAGER MOHAMMED ALWAYS IS TO
DIVE INTO ANY SITUATION WITH
DETERMINATION AND RESILIENCE.
HIS WILLINGNESS TO TAKE ON ALL
TASKS, NO MATTER HOW DAUNTING,
SPEAKS VOLUMES ABOUT HIS
CHARACTER AND COMMITMENT.
MOHAMMAD ENJOYS SIMPLE PLEASURES
OF LIFE CHEESE PIZZA FROM PIZZA
SUPREME BEING AND WWE. IN FACT,
HE'S ALREADY PLANNING HIS NEXT
VACATION TO LAS VEGAS TO
COINCIDE WITH WRESTLEMANIA. IT'S
TRUE, HIS KNOWLEDGE OF
PROFESSIONAL BASKETBALL IS
UNENDING AND EXTREMELY
IMPRESSIVE, THOUGH A LITTLE BIT
MISGUIDED IN WHO HE ROOTS FOR.
AND I'M GLAD TO NOTE THAT, LIKE
ALL SENATE STAFFERS, TRULY WORTH
THEIR SALT. THIS IS MR. NEWMAN.
HE IS A HARDCORE LAKERS FAN, SO
MOHAMMED IS DEEPLY CONNECTED TO
AND GRATEFUL FOR HIS PARENTS.
RABAB SULTAN AND AYAD AL HABIB,
WHOSE UNWAVERING SUPPORT HAS
BEEN HIS ANCHOR THROUGH HIS
JOURNEY IN PUBLIC SERVICE AND
PUBLIC POLICY. SO FAR, WE'RE
PLEASED TO HAVE THEM HERE IN THE
GALLERY, ALONG WITH HIS BROTHERS
JAFFER AND, MUHTATHIR. AND ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR NEWMAN AND
MYSELF, I HAVE TO JUST ADD A
PERSONAL, COMMENT. HE IS A NICE,
SERIOUS YOUNG PERSON. AND AS
SENATOR NEWMAN SAID, ALWAYS
WILLING TO JUMP IN AND DO
WHATEVER NEEDS TO BE DONE. I
KNOW SENATOR NEWMAN IS VERY
THANKFUL TO HAVE HAD HIM IN HIS
OFFICE, AS AM I, AND SO PLEASE
CONGRATULATE MOHAMMED.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR PADILLA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, THIS WITH
GREAT PRIDE THAT I RISE TO
RECOGNIZE SOMEONE WHO HAS BECOME
A CRITICAL PART OF TEAM PADILLA
HERE IN THE CAPITOL. MY SENATE
FELLOW CC SIDLEY CC WAS BORN AND
RAISED HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
ATTENDED CHRISTIAN BROTHERS HIGH
SCHOOL BEFORE HEADING TO THE
EAST COAST, THE UNIVERSITY OF
RHODE ISLAND, WHERE SHE WAS A
DIVISION ONE PITCHER FOR THEIR
SOFTBALL TEAM, GO RAMS. HER
SOPHOMORE YEAR, CC LED THE TEAM
IN WINS, IN PART THANKS TO HER
UNHITTABLE RISE BALL. OFF THE
FIELD, SHE WAS AN INCREDIBLE
STUDENT, DOUBLE MAJORING IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND CRIMINOLOGY WITH A
MINOR IN CONSERVATION BIOLOGY.
CC CITES HER STUDIES AND HOW
LUCKY SHE WAS TO GROW UP IN
CALIFORNIA WITH ITS DIVERSITY OF
OPINION AND OPPORTUNITY AS THE
REASON SHE APPLIED FOR THE
FELLOWS PROGRAM, AND WE ARE
CERTAINLY GRATEFUL THAT SHE DID.
UPON JOINING OUR OFFICE, CC
JUMPED RIGHT INTO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS, RUNNING
SEVERAL BILLS AND STAFFING
MULTIPLE COMMITTEES. WHAT STANDS
OUT ABOUT CC? PRETTY QUICKLY IS
HER AMAZING ANALYTICAL
CAPABILITIES. THAT QUICK
COMPREHENSION OF COMPLEX
LEGISLATIVE PROCESSES, AND AN
EYE FOR GOOD POLICY. AND I, FOR
ONE, KNOW A FELLOW POLICY NERD
WHEN I SEE ONE. SHE'S MOST PROUD
OF HER WORK ON SB 990, WHICH
DIRECTS CAL OES TO UPDATE OUR
EMERGENCY PLANS TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR LGBTQ+ COMMUNITIES
RECEIVE EQUITABLE CARE DURING
AND AFTER AN EMERGENCY. SHE ALSO
PLAYED A VITAL ROLE IN
RESEARCHING SOME OF THE HARDEST
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES
FACING THE STATE, AND WORKING
WITH ME ON BILLS TO ADDRESS
POLLUTION IN THE TIJUANA RIVER
WATERSHED. I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR
HER ENERGY AND OPTIMISM.
OPTIMISM THAT SHE BRINGS TO OUR
OFFICE EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND IN
FACT, WE LEARN FROM HER AS SHE
LEARNS AS WELL. FOR INSTANCE,
THOSE OF US OF A CERTAIN AGE IN
HER OFFICE DIDN'T KNOW THAT
OLIVIA RODRIGO WAS ACTUALLY PUNK
ROCK, BUT WHO KNEW? HERE TODAY,
TO CELEBRATE WITH CC, OUR HER
MOM, BRANDI AND HER SISTER
SOPHIE. UNFORTUNATELY, CC'S DAD
JASON RECENTLY PASSED AWAY
EARLIER THIS YEAR, BUT I KNOW
AND SHE KNOWS AND WE CAN
REASSURE HER THAT CERTAINLY HER
DAD IS VERY MUCH HERE TODAY AND
I WANT TO LET MY COLLEAGUES KNOW
IT IS MY STRONG INTENTION TO DO
EVERYTHING I CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT PERHAPS CC WILL JOIN OUR
TEAM WHEN HER TIME IN THE
PROGRAM ENDS. COLLEAGUES. MR.
PRESIDENT, PLEASE HELP ME IN
WELCOMING AND RECOGNIZING CC
SIDLEY.
THANK YOU. OH PERFECT.
SENATOR WILK, THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE
MEMBERS IF YOU COULD TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR SO
WE CAN DEDICATE OUR FOCUS AND
ATTENTION TO OUR FELLOWS BEING
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, THIS IS MY
12TH AND FINAL YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE, AND I HAVE BEEN
BLESSED FOR TEN OF THOSE 12
YEARS TO HAVE A FELLOW. AND I
KNOW IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF ME, BUT
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE GREAT STAFF
THAT I'VE HAD THROUGH THE YEARS.
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK ALL MY
STAFF FOR THE WORK THAT THEY'VE
DONE, RAISING UP THE NEXT
GENERATION OF LEADERS. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK JAMIE TAYLOR,
WHO'S BEEN WITH ME THE WHOLE
TIME, AND EVEN WHEN YOU'RE A
LEADER, YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
GET A FELLOW ABOUT EVEN ONE YEAR
WHEN I WAS LEADER, I'VE GOT A
FELLOW AND WANT TO APPRECIATE
HIM REALIZING THE VALUE OF
HAVING PEOPLE IN AN OFFICE THAT
THAT FUNCTION SO WELL. SO I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU TO, OH,
YOU'RE THERE. YOU'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO MY FELLOW
CONNOR JAMES SLOAN. HE IS THE
FIRST BEGOTTEN SON OF JIM AND
MICHELLE SLOAN, AND HE HAILS
FROM GRANITE BAY, SO HE'S LOCAL.
HE GRADUATED IN THREE YEARS FROM
THE REAL CAL POLY. CAL POLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO, WHERE HE WAS A STUD
RUGBY PLAYER UNTIL HE HE BLEW
OUT HIS KNEE. SO HE HAD A VISION
OF BECOMING A PROFESSIONAL RUGBY
RUGBY PLAYER. THAT'S NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN. SO HE'S NOW HE'S
TURNED HIMSELF TOWARDS PUBLIC
SERVICE, HIS NICKNAME AND I IN
OUR OFFICE IS BORN READY BECAUSE
WE THROW STUFF AT THIS KID ALL
THE TIME. AND HE'S HE'S LIKE,
ALWAYS READY TO DO IT. IN FACT,
HONESTLY, I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHO
HE WAS FOR THE TWO MONTHS, THE
FIRST TWO MONTHS BECAUSE HE WAS
NEVER IN THE OFFICE, BECAUSE HE
WAS OUT GETTING PEOPLE TO SIGN
ON AS COAUTHORS, TO OUR BILL
PACKAGE. HE'S ALSO VERY
CONSTITUENT ORIENTED, WHERE HE
SLASHES THROUGH THE RED TAPE TO
HELP OUR CONSTITUENTS. ONE DAY,
SOMEBODY CALLED THE OFFICE, AND
THERE'S TWO PEOPLE IN THE
OFFICE, HIM AND OUR CHIEF OF
STAFF, EILEEN RICKER. AND HE
SAID THAT I WAS NOT I WAS NOT
HERE, BUT OUR CHIEF OF STAFF IS
HERE, AND SHE'S NOT DOING
ANYTHING. SO LET ME PUT YOU ON
THE PHONE WITH HER, AND THE AND
THE PERSON WHO, I GUESS CALLS
ALL THE TIME WAS SO EXCITED.
IT'S THE FIRST TIME THAT THAT
WOMAN HAS EVER TALKED TO A CHIEF
OF STAFF OR A SENATOR IN HER
ENTIRE CAREER OF CALLING OUR
OFFICE. SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT. THAT'S GREAT WORK.
ALSO, AS YOU KNOW, SENATE
STAFFERS ARE NORMALLY OLDER, SO
THEY WANT TO DO THEIR JOB AND
JUST GO HOME. THEY DON'T HAVE
THE SAME ENTHUSIASM AS THE YOUNG
ASSEMBLY STAFFERS HAVE. AND SO I
MEET HIM. HE'S VERY SOCIAL. SO I
MADE HIM MY BODY, MY BODY, MAN,
SO HE COULD, YOU KNOW, NETWORK
PEOPLE WHEN WE GO OUT. SO WE'RE
GOING OUT ONE NIGHT, GOT FOR
EVENTS, GOING TO THE SECOND
EVENT, AND THERE'S A LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIAL THERE WHOM I
DON'T LIKE. I'M SURE WE ALL HAVE
ELECTED OFFICIALS. WE DON'T
LIKE. I SAID, LOOK AT TEN
MINUTES AND THEN WE'RE OUT OF
HERE AND MAKE SURE WE'RE OUT OF
HERE. SO THEY'RE IN MY ELECTED
OFFICIALS DRONING ON AND ON AND
ON, AND THEY'RE LIKE, WHERE'S
CONNOR? WHERE'S CONNOR? AND THEN
I TURN AND HE'S AT THE BAR WITH
LIKE, ENTERTAINING THREE PRETTY
GIRLS. AND I'M TRYING TO GET HIS
ATTENTION. SO THAT'S THE LAST
TIME HE DID THAT, THOUGH. HE
REALLY STEPPED UP HIS GAME AFTER
THAT. IN TERMS OF WHAT HE'S DONE
LEGISLATIVELY, HE'S DONE
EVERYTHING WE'VE ASKED HIM TO
DO, SO HE SO MY LD, I'M MATT
GALLAGHER, I DON'T THINK HE
LIKES HE EITHER LIKES DOES NOT
LIKE HIM OR REALLY RESPECTS HIM
BECAUSE HE DID JACK, WHICH IS
FINE. BUT THEN HE ALSO STAFFED
ON JUDICIARY AND EDUCATION,
WHICH ARE HEAVY LIFT COMMITTEES,
AS YOU KNOW, AND THEY'RE STACKED
ONE ON TOP OF ANOTHER. SOMETIMES
WE END AT 11 P.M. IN JUDICIARY,
AND THEN WE GOT TO BE BACK AT 9
A.M. THE NEXT MORNING, AND HE'S
JUST DONE A PHENOMENAL JOB WITH
THAT. HE'S DONE FOUR BILLS FOR
ME, LET'S SEE IF THEY GET
KILLED. AND WE'RE STILL GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS. BUT ONE OF
THEM, IF WE'RE SUCCESSFUL, IS
GOING TO ACTUALLY, BE VERY
HELPFUL TO, TO TAXPAYERS AND
ALSO TO ANIMALS, BECAUSE WE'VE
GOT A BILL THAT THERE'S A
PROCESS THAT YOU CAN USE TO SPAY
AND NEUTER ANIMALS BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW, BUT SO MANY OF THESE
ANIMAL SHELTERS NOW ARE JUST
KILL ZONES BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY. THERE ARE SO MANY ANIMALS
IN THERE AND NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE
TO WANTING TO ADOPT THEM. SO
HE'S BEEN FANTASTIC. HE'S
CERTAINLY BEEN MY MOST COLORFUL,
FELLOW THAT, THAT I'VE HAD IN
MANY RESPECTS. IT REMINDS ME OF
ME, WHICH IS KIND OF SCARY AT
TIMES, BUT, I WISH HIM NOTHING.
NOTHING BUT THE BEST MOVING
FORWARD. I THINK HE HAS AN
INCREDIBLY BRIGHT FUTURE, AND
HE'S NOT AFRAID TO SET TRENDS.
YOU KNOW, THINGS COME INTO STYLE
AND OUT OF STYLE. SO IN STYLE,
IN THE 70S WAS THE MUSTACHE HAS
BEEN OUT OF STYLE, BUT HE'S
BRINGING IT BACK INTO STYLE. SO
YOU GOT TO RESPECT THAT. SO 2 OR
3 YEARS FROM NOW WHEN ALL YOU
GUYS ARE WEARING MUSTACHES LIKE
THAT, YOU CAN THANK CONNOR
SLOAN. WITH THAT, I WANTED TO
SAY CONGRATULATIONS AND BEST OF
LUCK IN THE FUTURE.
SENATOR LAIRD, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS, I'M PLEASED TO
RECOGNIZE PAIGE SZABADI FOR THE
WORK THAT SHE HAS DONE THIS YEAR
IN MY OFFICE. SHE WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN COARSEGOLD, A SMALL
TOWN JUST OUTSIDE OF YOSEMITE
NATIONAL PARK. SHE ATTENDED THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
DAVIS, WHERE SHE RECEIVED
DEGREES IN POLITICAL SCIENCE,
PUBLIC SERVICE, AND
COMMUNICATION. THROUGHOUT THIS
YEAR, SHE HAS STAFFED ME ON A
MULTITUDE OF POLICY AREAS,
INCLUDING ON THE SENATE LABOR
COMMITTEE, NOT THE EASIEST
COMMITTEE TO STAFF, WHERE SHE
STAFFED MEETINGS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND CONSULTANTS,
AND ADVISED ME ON LEGISLATION
THAT CAME BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
SHE HAS STAFFED FIVE BILLS, AND
SHE WAS THE FIRST OF HER
FELLOWSHIP CLASS TO STAFF A BILL
THAT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW WHEN
THE WORLD'S AID DAY LAW WAS
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR, PAIGE IS
ALSO BECOME SOMEWHAT OF AN
EXPERT ON GIFT CARD LAW, HER
HARD WORK MADE HER A PLEASURE TO
HAVE IN THE OFFICE. HER SENSE OF
HUMOR IS ALWAYS IN EVIDENCE WHEN
PARTWAY THROUGH THE YEAR,
ANOTHER FELLOW WALKED UP TO ME
AND ASKED IF I HAD A FELLOW. I
KNEW THAT THAT FELLOW WOULD BE
TEASED MERCILESSLY FOR THE NEXT
PERIOD OF TIME, AND THAT PERSON
WAS SO. FOLLOWING HER FELLOWSHIP,
PAIGE HOPES TO CONTINUE
ADVOCATING FOR CALIFORNIANS ON
THE NATIONAL LEVEL IN
WASHINGTON, DC AS A LEGISLATIVE
STAFFER WITH THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS. THANK YOU PAGE FOR A
GREAT YEAR IN OUR OFFICE. WE'VE
LOVED WORKING WITH YOU. WE
ACTUALLY ARE GOING TO MISS YOU
GREATLY. CONGRATULATIONS ON A
GREAT YEAR.
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I NEED TO ASSURE MY
FELLOW I AM GOING TO STICK TO
THE TALKING POINTS AND NOT GO
OFF, SHE WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS
ABOUT THAT. IT'S WITH IMMENSE
PRIDE AND HEARTFELT JOY THAT I
STAND BEFORE ALL OF YOU TO
INTRODUCE A TRULY REMARKABLE
INDIVIDUAL. ARIANNA SZABO,
ACCOMPANIED TODAY BY HER PARENTS,
HER SISTERS AND HER BELOVED
GRANDMA, THEY ARE IN THE GALLERY
RIGHT UP THERE. ARIANNA IS NOT
ONLY A SHINING LIGHT FOR HER OWN
AS HER OWN, BUT AS SHE IS A
TESTAMENT OF STRENGTH AND
PERSEVERANCE AND LOVE FOR HER
ENTIRE FAMILY. ARIANNA ATTENDED
WILLIAM JESSUP UNIVERSITY, WHERE
SHE EARNED A DEGREE IN PUBLIC
POLICY, SHE HAD JUST COMPLETED
AN INTERNSHIP FOR PLACER COUNTY
SUPERVISOR BONNIE GORE WHEN I
MET HER AT A WILLIAM JESSUP
GRADUATION, SHE INFORMED ME SHE
INTRODUCED HERSELF, TOLD ME HER
PARENTS WERE AND INFORMED ME
THAT SHE WOULD BE MY NEW FELLOW
FOR THIS YEAR. I WAS REALLY
EXCITED THAT SHE WAS JOINING
TEAM GROVE AFTER SPENDING FIVE
MINUTES WITH HER AT THAT
GRADUATION, I KNEW SHE WAS GOING
TO FIT IN WITH OUR ENTIRE TEAM
JUST TREMENDOUSLY FROM THE VERY
MOMENT THAT ARIANNA STEPPED
THROUGH OUR DOORS, SHE BROUGHT
HER INFECTIOUS ENTHUSIASM,
UNWAVERING DEDICATION AND HER
CONTINUED HEART OF SERVICE FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS. AND SHE WOULD
ALWAYS TAKE THE TIME TO MAKE
SURE THAT SHE TALKED TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS, MADE THEM FEEL
LIKE THEY WERE BEING HELPED, AND
THEN REALLY ADDRESS THE ISSUE
THAT THEY HAD BEFORE THEM. SHE'S
BEEN WORKING ON LEGISLATION TO
EASE THE COMPLEXITIES,
SPECIFICALLY HER BILL FOR
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
THAT ARE GOING ON AS STUDENTS
STILL RECOVER FROM COVID. THAT
BILL IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE AND
ONLY ONE STEP AWAY FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. SO I'M REALLY
PROUD OF HER FOR GETTING THAT
BILL THROUGH THE ENTIRE
BUILDING, SHE'S WORKED ON HEALTH
RESOURCES AND WATER POLICY, AND
IN HER BRIEF TENURE WITH US,
ARIANNA HAS MANAGED FIVE
CRITICAL BILLS, ONE OF WHICH I
JUST EXPLAINED AND THE OTHER ONE
HAS ALREADY ONE HAS ALREADY BEEN
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR, BEYOND
HER IMPRESSIVE INTELLECT,
ARIANNA IS A DELIGHT. SHE'S GOT
A DELIGHTFUL WIT. SHE'S AN
EXTRAORDINARY SENSE OF HUMOR.
IT'S A VERY DRY SENSE OF HUMOR.
AND YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHEN SHE'S
JOKING AND SHE'S NOT. IT'S A
DETERMINATION THAT YOU HAVE TO
MAKE. AND AS SHE PREPARES TO
EMBARK ON HER NEXT ADVENTURE,
I'M CONFIDENT THAT SHE'LL FACE
WHATEVER CHALLENGES THAT COME
HER WAY WITH COURAGE AND THE
BRILLIANCE THAT SHE'S
DEMONSTRATED IN OUR OFFICE. I'M
SO PROUD THAT SHE'S PART OF TEAM
GROVE, AND I KNOW THAT GOD WILL
BLESS HER IN EVERYTHING THAT SHE
PUTS HER HANDS TO, BECAUSE SHE
REALLY IS A CORE, SOLID, JUST AN
INCREDIBLE INDIVIDUAL FROM THE
INSIDE OUT. SO I JUST THANK YOU
FOR BEING A PART OF MY TEAM.
SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. TODAY I AM ALSO
HONORED TO RECOGNIZE RYAN
TOMLINSON, WHO HAS MADE AN
INCREDIBLE CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
TEAM. AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU
ALL, WHAT I LIKE ABOUT RYAN IS
ON THE VERY FIRST DAY, HE SAID,
BOSS, EVERY ONE OF YOUR BILLS IS
GOING TO GET SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR. SO WE KEPT HIM BASED
ON THAT PLEDGE. SO IT'S GOOD. SO
WE'RE HOLDING HIM RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT. IF, IF, HAD TO DEVIATE
FROM THE SCRIPT. RYAN WAS BORN
ON FEBRUARY 3RD, 2000, IN
SACRAMENTO, CALIFORNIA, AND HAS
BEEN A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO FOR MORE THAN 20
YEARS. AFTER GRADUATING FROM
JOHN F KENNEDY HIGH SCHOOL, HE
ATTENDED CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO, RYAN'S LEADERSHIP WAS
EVIDENT EARLY ON AS HE SERVED AS
A STUDENT ADVISOR TO THE DEAN
AND FOUNDED THE GRADUATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION. HE ALSO SPENT HIS
LAST YEAR WORKING IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THE CITY OF SAN
LUIS OBISPO, WHERE HE HELPED
IMPLEMENT CITY WIDE POLICIES. HE
GRADUATED FROM CAL POLY IN FIVE
YEARS WITH BOTH HIS BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN POLITICAL SCIENCE AND
HIS MASTERS IN PUBLIC POLICY.
UPON BEING ACCEPTED TO THE
CAPITAL, FELLOWS PROGRAM, RYAN
WAS PLACED IN MY OFFICE AND HAS
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN STAFFING
AND ADDRESSING CRITICAL ISSUES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HE HAS WORKED ON FOUR
SIGNIFICANTLY COMPLEX BILLS THAT
ADDRESS ISSUES RANGING FROM
EDUCATION, THE OPIOID CRISIS TO
TAXES AND PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS. ONE OF THE BILLS IS
EXTREMELY COMPLICATED, WITH LOTS
OF MOVING PARTS, AND HE HAS DONE
A FANTASTIC JOB NAVIGATING THAT
THROUGH THE SYSTEM. BEYOND HIS
LEGISLATIVE WORK, RYAN HAS
SHOWED A DEEP COMMITMENT TO
SERVICE EVEN OUTSIDE THE
CAPITOL. HE WAS ELECTED AS THE
FELLOWS REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER CAPITAL
ASSOCIATION, WHERE HE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO SERVE AND UPLIFT THE
AAPI COMMUNITY THROUGH HIS
WONDERFUL WORK. RYAN'S
FELLOWSHIP EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN
TRANSFORMATIVE NOT ONLY FOR HIM,
BUT FOR ALL OF US WHO HAVE HAD
THE PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH HIM
ON A DAILY BASIS. HE TRULY IS A
NICE PERSON AND IT IS VERY FUN
JUST TO BE AROUND HIM BECAUSE
HE'S GOT THAT SMILE THAT JUST
SAYS HE'S ENJOYING HIMSELF, AND
THAT'S WHAT WE LOVE ABOUT HIM.
HIS ATTRIBUTES, HIS DRIVE, HIS
DEDICATION TO THE FOUNDATION
LAID BY HIS PARENTS, RICK AND
TAMMY. WHO HAVE DONE A FANTASTIC
JOB. HE ALSO ATTRIBUTES MUCH OF
HIS SUCCESS TO THE UNWAVERING
SUPPORT OF HIS TWO YOUNGER
SISTERS, MIA AND CHRISTY. AND
THEY'RE ALL IN THE GALLERY TODAY.
I KNOW THIS IS THE ONLY ONLY THE
BEGINNING FOR RYAN AND I'M
EXCITED TO SEE EVERYTHING THAT
HE WILL ACHIEVE IN THE FUTURE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
THE EXCEPTIONAL CONTRIBUTIONS OF
RYAN AND SEE WHAT HE DOES IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR RUBIO, YOUR NEXT. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY,
IT'S WITH GREAT HONOR THAT I'M
HERE TO RECOGNIZE A WONDERFUL
INDIVIDUAL. WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT
FOSTERING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
LEADERS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RISE. SO AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER,
I AM SO EXCITED TO SEE SO MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE GROW AND BLOOM INTO
IMPRESSIVE MEMBERS OF THEIR
COMMUNITY. AND THIS YEAR, I'VE
SEEN THAT HAPPEN ONCE AGAIN WITH
SENATE FELLOW KIANA KOIZUMI
WALKER, AS PART OF TEAM RUBIO'S
CAPITOL OFFICE. KIANA IS AN
INCREDIBLE YOUNG WOMAN WITH A
BRIGHT FUTURE AHEAD. FROM AN
EARLY AGE, KIANA HAS SHOWN BOTH
HER LEADERSHIP ABILITIES AND
CARE FOR HER COMMUNITY. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, KIANA HAS CONTINUED
TO DEMONSTRATE KINDNESS,
COMPASSION, AND EMPATHY. WHETHER
INTERACTING WITH ELECTED
OFFICIALS, COLLEAGUES, CAPITAL,
STAKEHOLDERS, OR CONSTITUENTS
WHO ARE CALLING DESPERATELY FOR
HELP, KIANA UNDERSTANDS THE
HUMAN ASPECT OF WHAT WE DO HERE
IN THE CAPITOL. SHE UNDERSTANDS
THAT BEHIND EVERY POLICY
DECISION, THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS
WHOSE LIVES ARE AFFECTED VERY
PERSONALLY WITH THE WORK WE DO.
DURING HER TIME WITH MY CAPITOL
OFFICE, KIANA TOOK ON EVERY
RESPONSIBILITY I GAVE HER WITH
ENTHUSIASM AND WITH ATTENTION TO
DETAIL. SHE COMPLETED EVERY TASK
I GAVE HER. SHE'S INCREDIBLY
DILIGENT, THOUGHTFUL, AND
HANDLED HERSELF LIKE AN
EXPERIENCED PROFESSIONAL. SHE
HAS HELPED STAFF ME IN SO MANY
COMMITTEES. MY COMMITTEES SELECT
COMMITTEES. SHE ALSO REPRESENTED
ME IN AS MYSELF IN AN OFFICIAL
TOUR WITH THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON
ARTS, AND HELPED PUT TOGETHER AN
INCREDIBLE INFORMATIONAL HEARING
FOR ME ON SCHOOL, CLIMATE AND
STUDENT SAFETY IN MY DISTRICT
OFFICE. KIANA ALSO HELPED
NAVIGATE IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
THROUGH THE PROCESS, NEGOTIATING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
DEMONSTRATING HER COMMUNICATION
ABILITIES BY HELPING WITH PRESS
EVENTS AND SOCIAL MEDIA. KIANA
HAS TRULY DEMONSTRATED THE BEST
OF WHAT OUR YOUTH HAS TO OFFER.
WE HAVE SO MANY CHALLENGES
FACING CALIFORNIA, BUT I'M
GRATEFUL TO HAVE SOMEONE LIKE
KIANA THAT WILL CHANGE, NOT JUST
CALIFORNIA. IN A POSITIVE WAY,
BUT I CERTAINLY BELIEVE THAT SHE
WILL CHANGE THE WORLD.
CALIFORNIA IS IN GOOD HANDS WITH
SUCH INCREDIBLE TALENT. THANK
YOU. KIANA WALKER, FOR ALL THE
WORK YOU DID IN MY OFFICE AND TO
THE FAMILY FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET TO KNOW YOU THROUGH HER
EYES. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST,
SENATOR CORTEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'M PROUD TO
RECOGNIZE LAUREN NGUYEN, AN
EXCEPTIONAL MEMBER OF MY STAFF.
SHE'S A LIFELONG SACRAMENTO
RESIDENT WHO LITERALLY GREW UP
HERE IN THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO
AND ATTENDED SACRAMENTO STATE.
KNOWN BEST FOR HER QUICK WIT AND
ICONIC ROASTS. NOT ME, OF
COURSE, LAUREN IS BROUGHT A
DISTINCT SENSE OF HUMOR AND
SPIRIT TO MY OFFICE. SHE'S A
WELCOMING AND FRIENDLY FACE TO
ALL WHO WALK THROUGH OUR DOORS.
THE STAFF SAYS. A PERFECT
BALANCE OF SILLY AND SERIOUS.
THROUGHOUT HER FELLOWSHIP YEAR,
LAUREN HAS CONSISTENTLY PROVEN
TO BE A THOUGHTFUL, THOROUGH,
AND EFFECTIVE STAFFER. HER HIGH
QUALITY WORK ILLUSTRATES HER
PASSION FOR POLICY AND SERVICE
TO HER COMMUNITY. SHE'S STAFFED
CHALLENGING BILLS AND WITH EVERY
OBSTACLE, SHE'S RISEN TO THE
OCCASION. VERY, VERY IMPRESSIVE.
HER CONTRIBUTIONS TO HEALTH CARE
ACCESS POLICY ALONE WILL MAKE A
LASTING IMPACT. I'M PROUD OF
LAUREN FOR HER ACCOMPLISHMENTS
THIS YEAR. I'M GRATEFUL FOR HER
SERVICE TO MY OFFICE, MY
CONSTITUENTS, AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. LAUREN HAS BEEN A
PRIVILEGE TO HAVE YOU ON OUR
TEAM, AND WE'RE GOING TO MISS
YOU GREATLY.
SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, FAMILY,
FRIENDS IN THE GALLERY. FELLOWS,
IT'S AN HONOR OF MINE TODAY TO
BE ABLE TO GIVE THE FINAL
WELL-WISHING OF THE DAY, AS YOU,
GRADUATE FROM HERE AND CONTINUE
ON TO YOUR NEXT ADVENTURE IN
LIFE, I'M ENCOURAGED TO SEE SO
MANY DEDICATED YOUNG
PROFESSIONALS READY TO SPREAD
THEIR WINGS AND CONTINUE THEIR
CAREERS AS PUBLIC SERVANTS ON
BEHALF OF ALL CALIFORNIANS. TO
THE FELLOWS, I REMIND YOU THAT
EACH CONSTITUENT MATTERS. AND
WHILE THE WORK YOU DO HERE MAY
FEEL ABSTRACT, IT HAS ACTUAL
EFFECTS ON THE DAY TO DAY LIVES
OF EVERY CALIFORNIAN. TO THE
FAMILIES AND FRIENDS HERE TO
CELEBRATE WITH THEIR LOVED ONES,
BE PROUD OF THE WORK THAT YOUR
FELLOWS HAVE DONE THIS YEAR IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE CAPITOL. IT
IS NOT ALWAYS EASY TO KNOW WHAT
IS RIGHT, BUT THEY HAVE EACH
SHOWN. THEY HAVE EACH SHOWN UP
EVERY SINGLE DAY TO LEARN AND TO
GROW AND TO SHARE THEIR
EXPERTISE AND HELP US LEARN AND
GROW EVERY SINGLE DAY. MAY YOU
BE BLESSED ON YOUR ROADS GOING
FORWARD, AND I INVITE ALL OF THE
FOLKS THAT ARE HERE TODAY TO
CELEBRATE THIS TIME TO JOIN US
FOR A RECEPTION HONORING THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF ALL THESE
FINE FELLOWS AND THIS YEAR'S
FELLOWSHIP CLASS IN THE EUREKA
ROOM UNTIL 4:00 PM THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FELLOWS. ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO THIS YEAR'S
FELLOWS. WE'RE GOING TO NOW TAKE
A BRIEF PAUSE FOR SOME PHOTOS.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE FELLOWS
FIRST.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU
TO STEP BACK SO WE CAN GET TO
FELLOWS.
WISHING.
NOW STAY THERE. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THE PARTY JOIN YOU FOR THIS
NEXT PHOTO. WHERE'S MR.
PRESIDENT? ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT. AND NOW WE'RE GOING
TO ASK ALL MEMBERS TO COME IN
AND JOIN FOR A GROUP PHOTO. ALL
MEMBERS IN THE FELLOWS, PLEASE.
AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO BE BACK
TO BUSINESS IN 30S. WE'LL BE
BACK TO BUSINESS IN 30S.
SENATOR LAIRD, UNDER PRIVILEGE
OF THE FLOOR. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'M PROUD TO WELCOME
AND INTRODUCE A DISTINGUISHED
DELEGATION OF SENATORS FROM THE
SANTA FE PROVINCE OF ARGENTINA
TO THE SENATE FLOOR TODAY,
LEADING THE DELEGATION IS
SENATOR PHILIP MICHLIG, THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM, THE PRESIDENT
PRO TEMPORE TEMPORE OF THE
SENATE OF SANTA FE. HE HAS BEEN
A SUPPORTER OF THE CALIFORNIA
SANTA FE RELATIONSHIP FOR MANY
YEARS. HE WAS FIRST ELECTED TO
THE SANTA FE SENATE IN 1999,
MADE HIS FIRST OFFICIAL VISIT TO
CALIFORNIA IN 2005, SO THE
RELATIONSHIP IS ALMOST AS LONG
AS HIS CAREER. WE APPRECIATE HIS
FRIENDSHIP DURING THAT ENTIRE
TIME. HE IS JOINED BY HIS
COLLEAGUES SENATOR OSCAR ALFREDO
DAWSON, SENATOR LEONARDO ANDRES,
DIANA, SENATOR HERMAN EDUARDO
GIACOMINO AND SENATOR SENATOR
CEDROSENSIS. THESE SENATORS ARE
JOINED BY THEIR DELEGATION AT
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBERS RIGHT
BY ME, INCLUDING DIEGO SUAREZ
SUAREZ, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
FUNDACION NUEVA GENERACION
ARGENTINA. MANY OF YOU KNOW HIM
FROM HIS ACTIVE PARTICIPATION IN
CLIMATE CHANGE MITIGATION WORK.
I KNOW I MET HIM FIRST AT A COP
CONFERENCE. HE WAS A CO-CHAIR
FOR LATIN AMERICA FROM 2018 TO
2020. IN THE UNDER TWO
COALITION. AS YOU ARE AWARE, OUR
SENATE AND THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE PROVINCE OF SANTA FE HAVE
ENJOYED A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP FOR
MANY YEARS IN FACT, WE HAVE SENT
FIVE DELEGATIONS THERE OVER THE
LAST 20 YEARS, INCLUDING LAST
FALL'S TRIP THAT I WAS
PRIVILEGED TO JOIN, ALONG WITH
THE SENATOR FROM ORINDA AND THE
SENATOR FROM HAYWARD, WHERE WE
WERE GRACIOUSLY HOSTED BY THE
FOUNDATION. THIS RELATIONSHIP
HAS BEEN CELEBRATED BY THE SANTA
FE PROVINCE IN CALIFORNIA
THROUGH THE ENACTMENT OF SISTER
STATE STATUS FOR OUR TWO
LEGISLATURES. SO THIS IS A CLOSE
AND SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO NURTURE FOR
YEARS TO COME. WHILE THEY ARE
HERE, THE DELEGATION WILL MEET
WITH MANY OF YOU, AS WELL AS
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS, TO
TALK ABOUT RENEWABLE ENERGY,
CLIMATE CHANGE, CRIMINAL JUSTICE
POLICY. THEY WILL ALSO TRAVEL TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE BAY
AREA TO VISIT WITH BUSINESSES
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN BOTH
REGIONS, AND DON'T FORGET, THERE
WILL BE A RECEPTION TONIGHT AT
THE STANFORD MANSION BEGINNING
AT 530. WE HOPE, AS MANY OF YOU
COME BY AS CAN, SO PLEASE JOIN
ME IN GIVING A WARM CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE WELCOME TO THIS
DISTINGUISHED DELEGATE. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE, WE SAY WELCOME.
COPY 34, WE ALSO WANT TO TAKE
THIS TIME TO WISH A HAPPY
BELATED BIRTHDAY TO SENATOR
BRIAN JONES. HAPPY BELATED
BIRTHDAY.
ALL RIGHT. AS WE CONTINUE IN
THIS PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR,
SENATOR CORTEZ, YOUR NEXT.
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AS SOMEONE WHO SPENT THE FIRST
17 YEARS OF MY LIFE AS A FARM
WORKER IN MY VERY, VERY EARLY
YEARS IN THE HEAT OF AUGUST,
JUST LIKE THE HEAT THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING NOW, PICKING PRUNES
IN THE DAYS BEFORE MACHINERY, ON
HANDS AND KNEES WITH MIGRANT
FARM WORKERS AND YOUNG FARM
WORKERS LIKE MYSELF WORKING SIDE
BY SIDE, IT GIVES ME ABSOLUTE
PLEASURE AND HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
THE FARM WORKERS KNOWN AS THE
YOLO SIX, WHO WERE RECENTLY
RETALIATED AGAINST AND FIRED BY
THEIR AGRICULTURE EMPLOYER FOR
EXERCISING THEIR RIGHTS IN THE
WORKPLACE IN ORDER TO AVOID
HEAT, ILLNESS, INJURY OR DEATH.
THEY WERE HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
THEIR CASE IN A PRESS EVENT
EARLIER TODAY. WE WANTED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE THEM TO
ALL OF YOU. THEY REPRESENT
THOUSANDS OF FARM WORKERS ACROSS
THE STATE AND NATION WHO TOIL
DAY IN AND DAY OUT UNDER EXTREME
HEAT, EXACERBATED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE, OF COURSE, TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S FOOD ON OUR TABLES
EVERY SINGLE DAY AND NIGHT, I
KNOW FIRSTHAND HOW HIGH THE
STAKES ARE TO ONE'S HEALTH AND
SAFETY WHILE WORKING UNDER
EXTREME HEAT WEATHER CONDITIONS,
AND OUT IN THE FIELD. I HAD THE
ADVANTAGE MOST OF THE TIME AS A
YOUNG MAN OF WORKING IN AN
ORCHARD FARMING ENVIRONMENT
WHERE AT LEAST THERE WAS SHADE
AVAILABLE. THESE FARM WORKERS
WORK IN AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
THERE'S NO SHADE AVAILABLE,
UNLESS IT'S PROVIDED BY THEIR
EMPLOYMENT EMPLOYER. WITHOUT
HEAT PREVENTION MEASURES IN
PLACE, LIVES HAVE BEEN LOST AND
DESPITE CALIFORNIA'S LANDMARK
LEGISLATION BY THIS LEGISLATURE,
OF COURSE, OVER 19 YEARS AGO,
ADOPTING AND INSTITUTING HEAT
PREVENTION SOLUTIONS IN THE
WORKPLACE, IT IS DOCUMENTED THAT
JUST SHORT OF 50% OF FARM
WORKERS TODAY STILL REPORT THEIR
FARMER, THEIR FARMING EMPLOYER,
NOT COMPLYING WITH EXISTING LAW,
THE YOLO SIX WHO WERE RETALIATED
AGAINST FOR STANDING UP FOR
THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY DURING
THE RECENT HEAT WAVE, ARE HERE
WITH US TODAY AND I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE THEM. YOU'VE SEEN THE
LEGISLATION MOVING FORWARD IN
THE SENATE THAT ATTEMPTS TO DEAL
WITH THE PROBLEM. I AM GRATEFUL
TO ALL OF YOU WHO HAVE SUPPORTED
THAT MEASURE AND OTHER MEASURES
GOING FORWARD. AGAIN, TO PREVENT
ILLNESS, HEAT ILLNESS, BUT
MOREOVER, TO SAVE LIVES. THESE
ARE THE STATE'S BACKBONE
LIFELINE, ENSURING THAT WE HAVE
FOOD ON THE TABLE AND THEIR
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY CONTINUES
TO THRIVE. IT'S THROUGH THE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS OF THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS ASSOCIATION
THAT I HOPE TO SEE FURTHER
LEGISLATION TO PROTECT FOLKS
JUST LIKE THOSE HERE TODAY THAT
I'M ABOUT TO INTRODUCE. JOINING
US WITH THE UNITED FARM WORKERS.
WE HAVE JORGE SANTANA, MARIA
PAREDES, GERARDO REYES, ISIDRO
FIERROS, ERICA PATRICIA DELUCIA
BARROS, PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
FARM WORKERS, TERESA ROMERO, AND
LADY RANGEL. I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE GIVE THEM A WARM WELCOME.
A ROUND OF APPLAUSE. THANK YOU.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE, WE SAY WELCOME.
YES. NEXT UP, WE HAVE SENATOR
NGUYEN WITH THE FLOOR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES,
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO A LONG
ESTABLISHED AND WIDELY RESPECTED
SURFING CULTURE. I HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF REPRESENTING A
BEAUTIFUL STRETCH OF THE COAST
OF ORANGE COUNTY. THE 41 MILES
OF ORANGE COUNTY COAST FROM SEAL
BEACH TO SAN CLEMENTE, WHERE
THEY HOST EVERYTHING FROM
PRESTIGIOUS SURF COMPETITIONS TO
FESTIVALS, WELL-KNOWN SURF
CLOTHING AND EQUIPMENT
COMPANIES, EDUCATIONAL MUSEUMS
AND A TOURISM INDUSTRY THAT
SUPPORTS MANY CITIES IN OUR
COUNTY, INCLUDING HUNTING BEACH.
ALSO KNOWN AS SURF CITY USA. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS OBSERVED
HAS FIRST OBSERVED CALIFORNIA'S
SURFING DAY ON SEPTEMBER 20TH,
2018, FOLLOWING THE PASSAGE OF
MY BILL S SCR 122, WHICH I
INTRODUCED TO BRING AWARENESS
AND ATTENTION TO THE IMPACT THAT
SURFING HAS ON OUR STATE.
SEPTEMBER 20TH WAS ADOPTED BY
CALIFORNIA SURFERS SURFERS AS A
DAY TO UNIFY AROUND THEIR LOVE
OF THE OCEAN, THE SPORT AND THE
SPIRIT OF THE PERFECT WAVE.
BECAUSE OF THE ICONIC SURF
BREAKS IN HUNTINGTON BEACH, WE
GET TO HOST A NUMBER OF MAJOR
SURFING EVENTS, SUCH AS THE US
OPEN OF SURFING, WHICH ACTUALLY
WAS JUST THIS WEEKEND. WE EVEN
HAVE ONE OF THE FIRST SURFING
MUSEUMS, A SURFERS WALK OF FAME,
ON THE SIDEWALK OF MAIN STREET
AND THE INTERNATIONAL SURFBOARD
BUILDERS HALL OF FAME.
CALIFORNIA COASTLINE SPANS 1100
MILES, AND ITS BEACHES IN OUR
COASTAL AREAS GENERATE $1.15
TRILLION IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
ANNUALLY. THE UNITED STATES
BOASTS APPROXIMATELY 3.3 MILLION
SURFERS WHO SPEND BETWEEN 1.9
AND $3.3 BILLION EACH YEAR ON
LOCAL SURF SHOPS. THAT'S A LOT
OF MONEY. AMERICA'S SURFING
INDUSTRY ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY IN
CALIFORNIA, GENERATES OVER $6
BILLION IN ANNUAL RETAIL SALES
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LARGEST OCEAN
ECONOMY IN THE UNITED STATES,
RANKING NUMBER ONE FOR BOTH
EMPLOYMENT AND JOBS AND GROSS
STATE PRODUCT AT APPROXIMATELY
$41.9 BILLION. NOW THE EXCITING
PART IS TEAM USA WON IN THE AN
OLYMPIC GOLD MEDAL IN SURFING.
OUR CHAMPION IS CAROLINE MARKS,
WHO LIVES IN SAN CLEMENTE, MY
DISTRICT. SHE HAS WON SEVERAL
OTHER CHAMPIONSHIPS AND PLACED
FOURTH IN THE TOKYO OLYMPICS. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WATCH ANY OF
THE SURFING FROM THIS YEAR'S
OLYMPICS, BUT IT WAS HELD IN
TAHITI AND THOSE WAVES WERE UP
TO 21FT HIGH. MOST PEOPLE WOULD
NEVER ATTEMPT SOMETHING THIS
DANGEROUS. SO NEEDLESS TO SAY,
THIS SPORT REQUIRES A LOT OF
BRAVERY AND A GREAT DEAL OF
SKILLS. WE HAVE MANY SURFERS
FROM MY DISTRICT WHO HAVE WON
CHAMPIONSHIPS AROUND THE WORLD,
INCLUDING THREE WHO WON THE US
OPEN THIS PAST WEEKEND. GRIFFIN
GRIFFIN COLAPINTO FROM SAN
CLEMENTE, AND WE'VE GOT CONNOR
NUNA, IKA WASHI AND BRETT
SIMPSON FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH.
TODAY. I HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM SOME OF MY COASTAL
COMMUNITY AS WE RECOGNIZE
CALIFORNIA SURFING DAY. PLEASE
HELP ME IN WELCOME. FIRST, WE
HAVE PETER PETE TOWNSEND WAR NO
WAR CHAMPIONSHIP CHAMPION,
PIONEER AND BOARD MEMBER OF
SURFING WALK OF FAME. HE WAS
INDUCTED INTO HUNTINGTON BEACH
WALK OF FAME IN 1998 AND
AUSTRALIAN SURFING HALL OF FAME
IN 2001, AND ALSO RECEIVED A
LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT FROM SEMA
IN 2013. WE'VE GOT HERE KIM,
AARON JUSTICE, DIRECTOR OF
OPERATION FOR SURFING, THE
NATION'S CALIFORNIA, NICOLE
LETO, VICE PRESIDENT OF
ADMINISTRATION, COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT FROM VISIT HUNTON
BEACH. I'VE GOT HERE WITH ME MY
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIAL. I HAVE
HUNTON BEACH MAYOR GRACIE
VANDERMARK, HUNTON BEACH MAYOR
PRO TEM PAT BURNS, HUNTON BEACH
COUNCIL MEMBER TONY STRICKLAND,
HUNTON BEACH I'M SORRY, NEWPORT
BEACH COUNCILWOMAN ROBIN GRANT
AND SAN CLEMENTE MAYOR VICTOR
CALDWELL, AS WELL. PLEASE HELP
ME AND WELCOME OUR AND THANK MY,
MY CONSTITUENTS AND MY ELECTED
OFFICIAL FOR COMING ALL THE WAY
HERE TO RECOGNIZE CALIFORNIA
SURFING DAY. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
WELCOME YOU HERE TODAY. I ALSO
FORGOT TO RECOGNIZE MR. PRO TEM.
FORMER SENATOR TONY STRICKLAND,
WHO IS ALSO A COUNCIL MEMBER
FROM THE CITY OF HUNTING BEACH,
IS ALSO HERE.
ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS AT THIS TIME,
WE'LL BE TAKING UP THE FOLLOWING
SENATE THIRD READING ITEMS OUT
OF ORDER. OH, I'M SORRY. YOU
HAVE ONE MORE. ALL RIGHT. I'M
SORRY. YOU HAVE ONE MORE
PRESENTATION. I'M SORRY, SENATOR
NGUYEN. THANK YOU. MR.
PRESIDENT. AT THIS TIME, IT IS
MY HONOR TO PAY TRIBUTE TO THE
BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVE IN
THE REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM ARMED
FORCES. CAN YOU, CAN YOU? YOU
HAVE TO READ THE RESOLUTION
FIRST. THANK YOU. SECRETARY,
PLEASE RAISE. I DON'T HAVE THAT.
THAT'S FINE. MEMBERS, AT THIS
TIME, WE'LL TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING SENATE THIRD READING
ITEMS. OUT OF ORDER. FILE ITEM
39, SCR 103 AND FILE ITEM 41,
SCR 168. AFTER ADOPTION OF EACH
RESOLUTION, WE WILL MOVE TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR FOR THE
AUTHOR TO INTRODUCE THEIR GUESTS.
YOU WANT TO DO YOU NEED TO READ
IT OR YES. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 103 BY SENATOR
NGUYEN. RELATIVE TO VETERANS.
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT,
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO INTRODUCE
SCR 103 TO HONOR THOSE WHO HAVE
SERVED IN THE REPUBLIC OF THE
VIETNAM ARMED FORCES DEFENDING
VIETNAM AND THE VIETNAMESE
PEOPLE'S FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY.
FOR THOSE WHO DO NOT KNOW, THE
HOUR, THE ARVN IS THE ARMED
FORCES OF SOUTH VIETNAM WHO
SOUGHT WHO FOUGHT ALONGSIDE THE
UNITED STATE ARMED FORCES.
TRAGICALLY, THE COST OF THEIR
SERVICE WAS HIGH, WITH OVER
300,000 MEMBERS PAYING THE
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE IN THE FIGHT
FOR FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY. FOR
THOSE WHO SURVIVED, THE
CHALLENGES THEY FACE DID NOT END
ON THE BATTLEFIELD FACING
PROSECUTION. THESE INDIVIDUALS,
THESE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN, WERE
FORCED TO FLEE THEIR COUNTRY IN
SEARCH OF SAFETY, FREEDOM AND AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
THIS, DESPITE THOSE ADVERSARIES,
THESE VETERANS SUCCESSFULLY
REBUILT THEIR THEIR LIVES IN THE
NEW LAND. THIS DEMONSTRATED
THEIR REMARKABLE DETERMINATION
AND LOVE FOR THEIR FAMILY AND
THEIR COUNTRY, THEIR
CONTRIBUTION TO THEIR ADOPTED
COUNTRY AND THOSE WHO I WILL BE
PRESENTING HERE LATER, THEIR
ADOPTED COUNTRY IS ALL OVER THE
WORLD. MOST OF US HAVE LANDED IN
THE UNITED STATES, WHICH THEY
HAVE ENRICHED COMMUNITIES AROUND
THE WORLD AND THEIR LEGACY
CONTINUES TO INSPIRE FUTURE
GENERATIONS. TODAY, WE COME
TOGETHER TO EXPRESS OUR PROFOUND
GRATITUDE TO THESE VETERANS, TO
HONOR THEIR SERVICE. AND AT THIS
TIME, I ASK YOU TO RESPECT THE
Dð SUPPORT, AND I VOTE FOR SCR
103. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON. FINAL ITEM 39 ALAN ALVARADO
GILL I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLEY I DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN
I GLASER I GONZALEZ I GROVE I
HURTADO I JONES I LAIRD I LEHMAN
I MAGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN I NILO I OCHOA
BOGH I PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
RATH I RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I STERN I
UMBERG WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN MCGUIRE UMBERG.
IS 37 NOES ZERO? THE MEASURE
PASSES. SEN NGUYEN FOR
INTRODUCTIONS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AGAIN THANK YOU,
COLLEAGUE, FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO
HONOR THE REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM
ARMED FORCES DAY ON JUNE 19TH.
TODAY, AS TODAY, AS WE GATHER TO
EXPRESS OUR PROFOUND GRATITUDE
TO THESE VETERANS, TO HONOR
THEIR SERVICE AND SHOW THEIR
SACRIFICES ARE NEVER FORGOTTEN,
IT IS FITTING, AS MENTIONED,
THAT JUNE 19TH ANNUALLY AS
VETERANS OF THE REPUBLIC OF
VIETNAM ARMED FORCES DAY, A DAY
DEDICATED TO ACKNOWLEDGING THEIR
CONTRIBUTION OF THESE
EXTRAORDINARY INDIVIDUALS, THERE
ARE ONLY A FEW MEMBERS OF THE
ARMED FORCES VETERANS AMONG US
TODAY, AND THERE ARE SLOWLY
PASSING AWAY, BECAUSE OF TIME.
AND SO HERE I WANT TO JUST TO
REALLY THANK THEM BECAUSE THESE
INDIVIDUALS, ALLOWING AN
INDIVIDUAL LIKE ME WHO 20 YEARS
AGO COULDN'T EVEN SPEAK
VIETNAMESE WELL, HAS EMBRACED ME
THE NEXT GENERATION, TO BE ABLE
TO LEARN VIETNAMESE AND TO BE
ABLE TO LEARN THE SACRIFICES
THAT THEY'VE GIVEN TO VIETNAM
AND THE PEOPLE AND THE
VIETNAMESE PEOPLE. I AM SO
HONORED TO RECOGNIZE THEM HERE
TODAY ON THE SENATE FLOOR. WE
HAVE HERE WITH US. SOME ARE
HERE, SOME AREN'T. BUT I JUST
WANT TO ALSO MENTION THEIR NAME
TO RECOGNIZE THEM, LIEUTENANT
RICHARD BUI, LIEUTENANT CAO SUE,
CAPTAIN MINH NGUYEN, LIEUTENANT
MINH MANJU DAO, LIEUTENANT
COLONEL NGUYEN, LIEUTENANT
COLONEL TUONG LÀ, LIEUTENANT
HUONG PHAM, CAPTAIN QUANG PHAM,
LIEUTENANT MUAY THAI CAPTAIN HèA
VUONG, LIEUTENANT HY TAN VO.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING AND
THANKING THESE HEROES FOR THEIR
BRAVERY, SELFLESSNESS, AND FOR
PAVING THE WAY FOR INDIVIDUALS
LIKE MYSELF TO LIVE THE AMERICAN
DREAM. WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. WE SAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO ITEM 41. SENATOR
WAHAB, SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 168 BY
SENATOR WAHAB, RELATIVE TO
WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY. SENATOR
WAHAB, THANK YOU. I RISE TO
PRESENT SCR 168 WOMEN'S EQUALITY
DAY. WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY IS A
CELEBRATION OF THE 19TH
AMENDMENT, WITH WOMEN GAINING
THE RIGHT TO VOTE IN THIS
COUNTRY, VOTING IS A
FOUNDATIONAL RIGHT THAT WE MUST
NOT TAKE FOR GRANTED. IN FACT,
OFTENTIMES WE HEAR THAT THE PEN
IS MIGHTIER THAN THE SWORD, AND
IT'S TRUE EVEN TODAY. WE
PRACTICE THIS EVERY DAY AS WE
VOTE AND WRITE LEGISLATION. BUT
WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT IS VOTING.
STRIKING THAT PEN FOR THE PERSON
YOU WANT TO VOTE FOR AS VOTERS,
WE IMPACT NOT ONLY OUR LIVES AND
ELECTIONS, BUT WE ALSO DETERMINE
ELECTIONS. WE IMPACT THE LIVES
OF SO MANY OTHERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. WOMEN AROUND THE
WORLD SUFFER THE RIGHTS OF WOMEN
AROUND THE WORLD, INCLUDING
RIGHT HERE IN AMERICA, ARE
ALWAYS AT RISK TO EXTREMIST
VIEWS. WOMEN'S RIGHTS ARE TIED
TO FREEDOMS. THE RIGHT TO VOTE
IS FOUNDATIONAL FOR WOMEN'S
PARTICIPATION AND REPRESENTATION
IN DECISION MAKING. ALTHOUGH WE
ARE SEEING MORE WOMEN RUN FOR
OFFICE AND I'M VERY EXCITED TO
SEE THAT GENDER PARITY IN THE
SENATE WILL HAPPEN, AND I'M VERY
EXCITED TO SEE THE POSSIBILITY
OF THIS THIS NOVEMBER. NOW WOMEN
WILL DISAGREE WITH EACH OTHER ON
MANY TOPICS AS WE ALL ARE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DIFFERENT LIVED
EXPERIENCES AND DIFFERENT
VALUES. THE RIGHT TO VOTE AND
VOTING IN GENERAL IS NONPARTIZAN.
WHETHER YOU'RE A WOMAN WHO'S A
DEMOCRAT OR A WOMAN WHO IS A
REPUBLICAN, OR SOMEONE THAT IS
STILL UNSURE THE RIGHT TO VOTE
IS ABOUT THE VALUES WE
PRIORITIZE, A RIGHT THAT WE
CAN'T TAKE FOR GRANTED. AND
OFTENTIMES I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
TO FOLKS THAT STILL WANT TO
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE VOTING FOR. THE
ENTIRE PURPOSE IS TO EDUCATE
YOURSELF, UNDERSTAND YOUR
VALUES, AND VOTE YOUR CONSCIENCE.
PEOPLE DEPEND ON US AND OUR
REPRESENTATION. WE REPRESENT THE
VALUES, CHARACTER, AND SENSE OF
INTEGRITY THAT RESONATES WITH
OUR CONSTITUENTS. WE VOTE TO
IMPROVE PEOPLE'S LIVES. THE
RIGHT TO VOTE IS FOUNDATIONAL TO
THAT FOR ALL OF US. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
SKINNER? THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SCR 168 HERE IN THIS
FINAL, TIME IS MY CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS, AND
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN WERE ACTUALLY GIVEN THE
RIGHT TO VOTE IN OCTOBER 1911,
BECAUSE THE CALIFORNIA VOTERS AT
THAT TIME PASSED THE EQUAL
SUFFRAGE MEASURE. THE AMENDMENT
FOR THE WHOLE COUNTRY WASN'T
RATIFIED UNTIL 1920. IN AUGUST,
HOWEVER, CALIFORNIANS DID IT IN
OCTOBER 1911. BUT I SAY SOME
WOMEN, BECAUSE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, THAT MEASURE
EXCLUDED OUR NATIVE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN. NOW WE HAVE WE ARE
LEGITIMATELY AND RIGHTFULLY
CELEBRATING THIS RIGHT TO VOTE.
BUT SINCE THE US SUPREME COURT
GUTTED THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT
JUST TEN YEARS AGO, STATES NOT
CALIFORNIA BUT MANY OTHERS HAVE
PASSED NEARLY 100 LAWS
RESTRICTING VOTER RIGHTS. SO
THERE'S MORE TO DO, AND THERE'S
A LOT MORE TO DO TO ACHIEVE
GENDER EQUITY. WOMEN OWNED
STARTUPS RECEIVE LESS THAN 3% OF
VENTURE CAPITAL. WOMEN MAKE UP
ONLY 14% OF VC VENTURE CAPITAL.
DECISION MAKERS. WOMEN RUN
NONPROFITS, OR THE NONPROFITS
THAT SERVE PRIMARILY WOMEN,
RECEIVE ONLY 1% OF PHILANTHROPIC
DOLLARS THAT SURPRISED EVEN ME
WHEN I FOUND THAT WOMEN SMALL
BUSINESSES RECEIVED FEWER BANK
LOANS, AND WHEN THEY GET THEM,
THE LOANS ARE SMALLER AND THE
INTEREST RATE IS HIGHER. ONLY
10% OF OUR FORTUNE 500 CEOS ARE
WOMEN, 8.2% OF STANDARD AND
POOR'S 500 COMPANIES CEOS ARE
WOMEN, AND MORE WOMEN,
ESPECIALLY AS WE GET OLDER, ARE
LIVING IN POVERTY AND WE CANNOT
UNDERESTIMATE THE FULL ON
ASSAULT ON WOMEN'S BODILY
AUTONOMY. A RIGHT THAT WE
ACHIEVED OVER 50 YEARS AGO. BUT
WITH THE COURTS DECISION TO
OVERTURN ROE V WADE WAS
STRIPPED. SO THERE'S MORE WORK
TO DO. IN THE LAST FEW YEARS, I
WAS BEGINNING TO FEEL
DISCOURAGED THAT WE HADN'T
GOTTEN MUCH PAST MY TIME IN
KINDERGARTEN. WHEN MY
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER ASKED ALL
OF US IN CLASS, HE SAID, WE'RE
GOING TO DO A CIRCUS. KIDS AND
YOU ALL GET TO PICK WHICH ROLE
YOU WANT TO BE IN THE CIRCUS
CIRCUS. SO I SHOT UP MY HAND.
SHE CALLED ON ME AND I SAID, SHE
SAID, NANCY, WHAT DO YOU WANT TO
BE FOR THE CIRCUS? AND I SAID,
THE RINGMASTER, WHAT DID SHE
TELL ME? NO. SORRY, GIRLS CAN'T
BE THE RINGMASTER. I DON'T
REMEMBER WHAT ROLE I PLAYED IN
THAT CIRCUS. I DON'T REMEMBER
THAT CIRCUS AT ALL. BUT TODAY,
THIS YEAR, WE WILL HAVE, I
BELIEVE, A WOMAN RINGMASTER WHEN
WE ELECT THE FIRST WOMAN
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
SO MY TEACHER WAS WRONG. THERE
HAS BEEN PROGRESS. YES, MORE TO
DO. BUT THERE'S BEEN PROGRESS.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM HAYWARD
POINTED OUT, THIS DECEMBER,
THERE WILL BE GENDER PARITY ON
THIS RED CARPET AND Dð TO
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP AND THE
SUPPORT OF OUR GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
FINANCIAL AND OTHER SUPPORT FOR
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES HAVE
INCREASED. WE HAVE EQUAL PAY
LAWS. WE HAVE MUCH IMPROVED
PARENTAL LEAVE AND SICK PAY
LAWS. WE HAVE PAY EQUITY AND
INVESTMENT EQUITY DISCLOSURE
LAWS. WE HAVE INCREASED WAGES TO
THE OH SO ESSENTIAL CHILD CARE
WORKERS WHO ALSO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, ARE THE FIRST IN THE
NATION TO RECEIVE RETIREMENT
BENEFITS AND THOSE OF YOU WHO
MAY HAVE BEEN WATCHING THE
OLYMPICS, AMERICAN WOMEN
DOMINATED THOSE OLYMPICS. WE
BROUGHT HOME HALF OF THE USA'S
MEDALS OUT OF THE 126 MEDALS
GIVEN TO AMERICAN ATHLETES,
WOMEN RECEIVED A WHOPPING 67 OF
THEM. WE CAN THANK TITLE NINE
FOR GETTING US TO THAT POINT.
TITLE NINE DIDN'T JUST SAY, OH,
WE HOPE SPORTS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS ARE MORE EQUITABLE. IT
WAS A GOVERNMENT MANDATE THAT
OUR EDUCATIONAL AND OTHER
INSTITUTIONS PUT AS MUCH EFFORT
AND DOLLARS INTO ATHLETICS AND
OTHER PROGRAMS FOR WOMEN AS IS
DONE FOR MEN, AND WE ARE REAPING
THOSE BENEFITS. WOMEN ARE
PASSING THE BATON ONTO THE
FINISH LINE. THE FUTURE IS
FEMALE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SCR 168. YES
SENATOR RUBIO, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE, TODAY I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SCR 168, WHICH
RECOGNIZES WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY
IN CALIFORNIA. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE SENATOR FROM HAYWARD
FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION FORWARD. WE HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES TO EMPOWER
WOMEN, BUT ATTACKS ON OUR RIGHTS
AND REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOMS
CONTINUE TO PERSIST THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY. SO OUR WORK IS NOT
DONE. GENDER INEQUALITY IS
PREVALENT IN MANY ASPECTS OF OUR
LIVES, ESPECIALLY IN THE
EDUCATIONAL AND ACADEMIC SPACES.
SO IT IS CRUCIAL THAT WE
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
WOMEN IN LEADERSHIP POSITIONS,
ESPECIALLY THESE AREAS. WOMEN
MUST HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE IN
ORDER TO CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA'S STRONG AND GROWING
ECONOMY. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE FOR STRONGER
PROTECTIONS AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR WOMEN AND ENSURE THAT OUR
PROGRESS IN THE STATE IS NOT
HINDERED BY THE EFFORTS ACROSS
OUR NATION TO ROLL BACK
PROTECTIONS AND HOLD WOMEN BACK.
THE RIGHT TO VOTE, THE RIGHT TO
HAVE REPRESENTATION AND THE
RIGHT TO LEAD IS FOUNDATIONAL TO
OUR COLLECTIVE SUCCESS. WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM, HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. SENATOR WHAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS, THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE ITEM
41? HEARING AND SEEING NO
OBJECTION. AYES 37, NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE MOVING BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. SENATOR
SKINNER, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU. SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN RECOGNIZING PIPER KERMAN,
A RESIDENT OF MY DISTRICT, AND
THE AWARD WINNING AUTHOR OF
ORANGE IS THE NEW BLACK. PIPER
IS IN SACRAMENTO TODAY TO JOIN
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
EQUALITY DAY RECEPTION, WHICH
WILL FOLLOW OUR FLOOR SESSION AS
EQUALITY DAYS. WE JUST
DISCUSSED, CELEBRATES THE
ADOPTION OF THE 19TH AMENDMENT,
WHICH GAVE WOMEN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE. PIPER IS AN APPROPRIATE
GUEST SPEAKER FOR THE EVENT. AS
A PERSON WITH A FELONY
CONVICTION, WHICH IS THE SUBJECT
OF HER BOOK IN MANY STATES,
PIPER'S RIGHT TO VOTE WOULD HAVE
BEEN FORFEITED OR IS FORFEITED
FOR HER LIFETIME, BUT NOT HERE.
PIPER IS BEST KNOWN FOR HER FOR
HAVING THE ADAPTATION OF HER
2010 BOOK BECOME ONE OF
NETFLIX'S NUMBER ONE OR FIRST
HIT SHOWS, AND ORANGE IS THE NEW
BLACK IS PIPER'S MEMOIR OF
SERVING 13 MONTHS AT THE FEDERAL
CORRECTION INSTITUTE IN DANBURY,
CONNECTICUT. AFTER HER RELEASE,
PIPER HAS BEEN A FEATURED
SPEAKER ABOUT AND HAS WRITTEN
ABOUT THE CONDITIONS WITHIN OUR
US PRISON SYSTEM. SHE'S BEEN
FEATURED IN THE NEW YORK TIMES,
HUFFINGTON POST ON NPR, CBS, AND
MORE. SHE'S ALSO TESTIMONY AT
CONGRESSIONAL HEARINGS. SHE NOW
WORKS AS A COMMUNICATIONS
STRATEGIST FOR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND HAS JUST
SUBMITTED THE MANUSCRIPT FOR HER
SECOND BOOK, FOCUSED ON HER FOUR
YEARS TEACHING AT A MEN'S
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY IN OHIO.
MEMBERS JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
PIPER KERMAN. WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
IF OTHER SENATORS WOULD LIKE A
PHOTO, NOW WOULD BE THE TIME.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING
ON WITH OUR DAILY BUSINESS.
WE'RE NOW AT MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS FROM
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. AND NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO MOTIONS AND
MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR AUGUST 5TH,
2024 THROUGH AUGUST 8TH, 2024
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTES CLERK. THERE ARE
FOUR AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK.
THEY WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1470 WILL BE
RETURNED TO THE ASSEMBLY. NOW
UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
RECOGNIZING MEMBERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO REMOVE AN ITEM. SENATOR
DORADO, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE PULL FILE ITEM
327 AB 2192 FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE DESK WILL NOTE
SENATOR LAMONT, THANK YOU. AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR,
PLEASE REMOVE AB 1168 FILE ITEM
A19 FROM THE INACTIVE FILE FOR
THE PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU. THE DESK WILL NOTE.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM
338 AB 2843 PETRIE-NORRIS TO BE
REMOVED FROM CONSENT FILE FOR
THE PURPOSES OF AMENDMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. JUST WILL NOTE,
SENATOR PADILLA. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. PLEASE REMOVE FILE
ITEM A1, SB 583 FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE, PLEASE REMOVE AB
1282 FILE ITEM A 21 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWENTHAL. PLEASE REMOVE
IT FROM THE INACTIVE FILE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR SECRETO. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR, I WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE AB 1862 FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND BACK TO THIRD
READING FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDING
DESK WILL NOTE. SENATOR WHO DO
WE HAVE NEXT? BLAKESLEA. PLEASE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM 332 AB 2533
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. THE DESK WILL
NOTE, SENATOR ASHBY. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR, PLEASE PULL FILE
ITEM 328 AB 2318 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PAPAN FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. OKAY. DESK WILL NOTE
SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO REMOVE
FILE ITEM 339 AB 2871
MAIENSCHEIN FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
THE NEXT DESK WILL NOTE, SENATOR
GLAZIER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, I'D LIKE TO ASK THAT
ASSEMBLY BILL 1913, FILE ITEM
321 BE REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THANK YOU. THE DESK
WILL NOTE. ALL RIGHT. THERE'S NO
MORE ITEMS. THE MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS WILL MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF A DAILY FILE.
NOW, SECOND READING FILE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 80.
ASSEMBLY BILL 382 832 1524 1953
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
182. ASSEMBLY BILL 1954 262
2832. THANK YOU. NOW MOVING TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS, WE HAVE
FIVE FIVE ITEMS. WE HAVE. FIRST
UP IS FILE ITEM 23. SENATOR
WIENER, HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 905 BY SENATOR WIENER. AN
ACT RELATING TO CRIMES. SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SENATE
BILL 905 IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS SPECIFY THAT
THE VALUE OF ILLEGALLY OBTAINED
PROPERTY POSSESSED BY A PERSON
WITHIN THE PAST TWO YEARS CAN BE
AGGREGATED TO DETERMINE THE
VALUE FOR PURPOSES OF A
VIOLATION UNDER SECTION TWO, THE
BILL IS SPONSORED BY SAN
FRANCISCO MAYOR LONDON BREED,
AND IS PART OF OUR, THE PRO TEMS
WORKING TOGETHER FOR A SAFER
CALIFORNIA PACKAGE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM, SENATOR GROVE? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS BILL
TALKS ABOUT TWO CRIMINAL
OFFENSES RELATED TO VEHICLE
BURGLARY, CRIME, AND FORCIBLY
ENTERING A VEHICLE, PLUS AN
ADDITIONAL LIST OF THINGS OF
UNLAWFUL ENTRY, BURGLARY, AND
THE. THE THING THAT I'M
INTERESTED IN IS TAMPERING WITH
A VEHICLE, WHETHER OR NOT THE
PERSON COMMITTED AN ACT OF VALUE
TO EXCEED $950 IN THE LANGUAGE.
SO QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
SENATOR WIENER, WILL YOU TAKE A
QUESTION? YES I JUST WANT TO
KNOW IF THIS COVERS CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION. WHICH TELL ME EXACTLY
WHAT CAN YOU TELL ME EXACTLY
WHAT, LANGUAGE YOU'RE REFERRING
TO, THROUGH THE CHAIR. SO THE
LANGUAGE TALKS ABOUT TAMPERING
WITH A VEHICLE, WHETHER OR NOT
THE PERSON COMMITTED THE ACT,
WHERE THE VALUE OF EXCEEDS $950,
LIKE TAKING SOMETHING FROM A
VEHICLE, WHETHER IT'S SEEDS,
$950. SO A CATALYTIC CONVERTER
IS WELL ABOVE $950. AND I JUST
WANT TO KNOW IF THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY WHAT I'M SORRY, THE
CATALYTIC THROUGH THE CHAIR.
WHICH SECTION? WHICH SECTION ARE
YOU REFERRING TO? SENATOR GROVE
THE EXACT LANGUAGE. IF WE COULD
Þ I COULD GET THE EXACT
LANGUAGE. I JUST HAVE IT
HIGHLIGHTED ON A NOTE THAT I
HAVE HERE UNDER SECTION OF THE
BILL. SO I APOLOGIZE, BUT I'D BE
GLAD TO GET THAT FOR YOU. THE
REASON WHY I ASKED THIS QUESTION
ON MY OWN TIME. SORRY ON YOUR
OWN TIME. THE REASON WHY I ASKED
THIS QUESTION IS BECAUSE IF YOU
HAVE A VEHICLE WITH A CATALYTIC
CONVERTER AND YOU TAKE IT OFF OF
YOUR OWN VEHICLE, THERE'S A
$10,000 FINE. BUT IF SOMEONE
ELSE TAKES IT OFF THEIR VEHICLE,
YOUR VEHICLE, AND SELLS IT, OR
GETS RID OF IT OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT, THERE'S MINIMAL
PUNISHMENT. THERE'S, A PIECE OF
THERE'S A PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
641 IN, IN PROCESS. BUT YOU HAVE
TO BE IN POSSESSION OF NINE
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS IN ORDER
TO, HAVE ANY PUNISHMENT OR
PUNITIVE ACTION IN THE LAW. AND
I'M JUST CURIOUS ABOUT THAT
PARTICULAR PIECE OF EQUIPMENT ON
A PIECE OF, ON A VEHICLE,
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS A HUGE
ISSUE WHEN IT COMES TO, YOU
KNOW, THEFT, THEFT. AND AGAIN,
YOU AS THE OWNER OF THE VEHICLE
UNDER CALIFORNIA STATE LAW, CAN
BE PUNISHED UP TO $10,000 FOR
TAKING ONE OF THOSE OFF OF YOUR
OWN VEHICLE. BUT IF SOMEBODY
ELSE STEALS IT, YOU HAVE TO BE
IN POSSESSION OF NINE. AND I
THINK IT'S JUST A SILLY LAW. AND
I WAS HOPING THAT THE AUTHOR
COULD TELL ME THAT IS INCLUDED
IN THIS, BECAUSE IT WOULD
EXCEED, $950, WHICH IS IN THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SEEING NO MORE
MICROPHONES, SENATOR WIENER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, THIS BILL IS ABOUT,
THE BREAKING INTO AND THEFT FROM
VEHICLES, WHICH HAS BEEN A
GROWING SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM, I
KNOW, IN SAN FRANCISCO AND MANY
OTHER JURISDICTIONS. FIRST AND
FOREMOST, IT CLOSES A LOOPHOLE
WHERE THE DA HAS HAD TO PROVE
NOT JUST THAT PERSON BROKE INTO
THE CAR, BUT THAT ALL THE DOORS
WERE LOCKED, IS REMOVES THAT
RIDICULOUS LOOPHOLE THAT HAS
UNDERMINED PROSECUTIONS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MEMBERS, THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM? YES, THERE IS. ALL
RIGHT. MR. SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NHIÀU AYE. OCHOA.
BORG. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. RATH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN MCGUIRE.
WHEN AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
UMBERG. AYES 36. NO ZERO. ON THE
OCCURRENCE OF AMENDMENTS. AYES
36. NÓ ZERO ON THE ITEM MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 24. SENATOR HOBBS. SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 982 BY SENATOR
WAHAB. AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMES. SENATOR WAHAB, THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SB 982, WHICH IS BACK FROM FOR
CONCURRENCE. I SHOULD SAY THIS
BILL SIMPLY ELIMINATES THE
JANUARY 1ST, 2026 SUNSET TO MAKE
THE CRIME OF ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT PERMANENT. SB 982 IS PART
OF THE SENATE'S BIPARTISAN SAFER
CALIFORNIA PACKAGE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S RETAIL THEFT PACKAGE,
WHICH WILL KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES
SAFE AND PROTECT OUR BUSINESSES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SENATOR NILO? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I WAS ORIGINALLY A
JOINT AUTHOR OF THIS BILL, AS I
HAD INTRODUCED A SIMILAR BILL,
BUT I PULLED OFF WHEN CERTAIN
AMENDMENTS WERE ADDED TO THAT
BILL BACK IN JUNE. IT HAS NOW
BEEN RESTORED TO ITS ORIGINAL
FORM. AND I DO SUPPORT THE BILL.
AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING? SEEING NONE.
SENATOR WAHAB, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? THANK YOU. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS,
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE. AYES
37. NO, ZERO ON THE CONCURRENCE.
AYES 37. NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
NOW MOVING ON TO FINAL ITEM 27.
SENATOR SKINNER, SHE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1144 BY SENATOR
SKINNER. AN ACT RELATING TO
BUSINESS. SENATOR SKINNER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SB 1144 INCREASES
REGULATIONS FOR ONLINE
MARKETPLACES TO PREVENT THE SALE
OF STOLEN GOODS. I AM TAKING IT
UP FOR CONFERENCE VOTE FROM THE
TECHNICAL TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE MADE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
THIS Tð IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. NO I'M
SORRY. WE NEED A ROLL CALL ON
THIS ONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO, GIL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS I BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DELI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ I. GROVE. AYE HURTADO
I. JONES. AYE LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN
AYE. MAGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
AYE. OCHOA BORG. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE. RATH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. MAGUIRE
WHEN? AYE UMBERG. ARCE 37 NOES.
ZERO. AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED.
AYES 37. MEASURE PASSES NOW.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 28 BY
SENATOR MEN. HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 1242 BY SENATOR MEN AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMES. SENATOR MEN.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS TO SB 1242
MADE NO SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? THERE IS AN
OBJECTION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 28,
ALAN ALVARADO. GO Ã ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS I BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALI. AYE DODD. AYE. Dð.
RUSSELL. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE LEHMAN. AYE. MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NEELO. AYE. OCHOA
BORG. AYE. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. RATH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN.
AYE UMBERG. WAHAB. AYE WIENER.
AYE. WILK AYE. SENATOR MIN MOVES
THE CALL NOW. MOVING ON TO ITEM
32 BY SENATOR NEWMAN. HE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1416 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMES. SENATOR NEWMAN AND FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 1416, WHICH IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE, WHICH WILL
IMPOSE A SET OF ESCALATING
ENHANCEMENTS FOR MIDDLEMEN
INVOLVED IN ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT AMENDMENTS TAKEN TO THE
ASSEMBLY. ADD A FIVE YEAR SUNSET
TO THE BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION? WE ALL
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE AN
OBJECTION.
YES. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE ITEM
32. HEARING AND SEEING. NONE WE
DO. WE DO HAVE AN OBJECTION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WE DO HAVE AN OBJECTION. A
COUPLE HEARSAY. ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE ARCHULETA I ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. I BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER I. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ I DEL. AYE
DODD I DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE I
HURTADO. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE
LIMÓN. AYE. MAGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MEN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE OCHOA. BOG
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO CIERTO AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
NO. STERN AYE. UMBERG WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
HURTADO. AYE MCGUIRE. RUBIO AYE.
UMBERG. AYES 36. NØ ZERO.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENT NOES ONE.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN NOW MOVING ON TO
SENATE. THIRD READING. WE HAVE
ONE ITEM. ITEM 45 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. HE IS READY TO GO.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 110 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD, RELATIVE TO PORT
CHICAGO 80TH ANNIVERSARY.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. S.R. 110, WHICH
RECOGNIZES THIS YEAR AS THE 80TH
ANNIVERSARY OF PORT CHICAGO
NAVAL MAGAZINE DISASTER. 80
YEARS AGO, ON JULY 17TH, 1944,
THE DEADLIEST HOME FRONT
DISASTER OF WORLD WAR TWO
OCCURRED AT PORT CHICAGO NAVAL
MAGAZINE AND CONCORD,
CALIFORNIA, WHEN AN EXPLOSION AT
THE FACILITY KILLED OR WOUNDED
710 PEOPLE, 32 I MEAN 320
INDIVIDUALS. THE IMMEDIATE
PROXIMITY OF THE BLAST WERE
KILLED INSTANTLY. AFRICAN
AMERICANS COMPRISED NEARLY TWO
THIRDS OF THOSE KILLED AT THE
TIME. THE NAVY BARRED AFRICAN
AMERICAN SAILORS FROM NEARLY ALL
SEAGOING BRANCHES, WHICH MEANT
THAT MOST OF THE NAVY'S ORDNANCE
BATTALIONS HERE AT HOME WERE
COMPRISED OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
ENLISTED PERSONNEL. MANY OF
THOSE OFFICERS STATIONED AT PORT
CHICAGO WERE OLDER RESERVISTS
RECALLED TO ACTIVE DUTY OR
JUNIOR OFFICERS WHO HAD LITTLE
OR NO TRAINING AND MINIMAL
LEADERSHIP EXPERIENCE, AND YET
THE NAVY'S REPORT ON THE
EXPLOSION RELIED ON RACIST
STEREOTYPES OF THE TIME TO IMPLY
THAT AFRICAN AMERICAN ENLISTED
PERSONNEL HAD BEEN DIFFICULT TO
TRAIN AND STORE IN THEIR
OPERATIONS. BUT RAISED NO
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
CONCERNING THE WHITE OFFICERS
LEADERSHIP RESPONSIBILITIES.
FOLLOWING THE DISASTER, THE
SURVIVING PERSONNEL WERE
TRANSFERRED TO PORT CHICAGO TO
THE MARE ISLAND NAVAL WEAPONS
STATION, WHERE THEY WERE AGAIN
ASSIGNED TO ORDNANCE LOADING
DUTIES UNDER THE SAME CONDITIONS
AT PORT CHICAGO. ON AUGUST 9TH,
258 OF THE SAILORS AT MORRIS
ISLAND REFUSED TO CARRY OUT
THEIR DUTIES UNLESS SAFETY
CONDITIONS WERE IMPROVED. THE
NEXT DAY, 208 SAILORS WHO
RETURNED TO DUTY RECEIVED COURT
MARTIALS FOR REFUSING FOR THEIR
REFUSAL TO OBEY ORDERS, AND WERE
SENTENCED TO FORFEIT OF THREE
MONTHS PAY, BUT 50 SAILORS, THE
PORT CHICAGO 50 CONTINUED TO
PROTEST THEIR DUTIES AND WERE
CHARGED WITH DISOBEDIENCE OF A
LAWFUL ORDER AND MUTINY, AND
THEY WERE SENTENCED TO 8 TO 15
YEARS OF CONFINEMENT AND RECEIVE
DISHONORABLE DISCHARGE FROM THE
MILITARY. FOR OVER 50 YEARS, THE
PORT CHICAGO 50 AND THEIR
DESCENDANTS REPEATEDLY APPEALED
TO CONGRESS AND THE NAVY THAT
HAVE THEIR NAMES AND RECORDS
CLEARED. IT WASN'T UNTIL
DECEMBER 1999 THAT FREDDY MEEKS,
AT THE TIME THOUGHT TO BE THE
LAST SURVIVING MEMBER OF THE
PORT CHICAGO 50, RECEIVED A
PRESIDENTIAL PARDON. THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
PASSED NUMEROUS RESOLUTIONS
CALLING FOR THESE MEN TO BE
EXONERATED, INCLUDING PREVIOUS
EFFORTS LED BY SENATOR FROM
ORINDA, SENATOR GLAZIER, AND
FORMER SENATOR SENATOR ROD
WRIGHT. LAST MONTH, ON JULY
17TH, THE SECRETARY OF THE NAVY,
CARLOS DEL TORO, EXONERATED THE
CART MARSHAL COURT MARTIAL
VERDICTS FOR ALL THE SAILORS
CONVICTED. SECRETARY DEL TORO
SAID THAT THIS ACTION WAS SIMPLY
THE RIGHT THING TO DO BASED ON
THE EVIDENCE WE DISCOVERED THE
PORT CHICAGO 50 AND THE HUNDREDS
WHO STOOD WITH THEM ARE NO
LONGER WITH US, BUT THEIR
STORIES LIVES ON AND A TESTAMENT
TO THEIR ENDURING POWER TO
ENCOURAGE AND THEIR UNWAVERING
PURSUIT FOR JUSTICE. SR 110
RECOGNIZES THE 80 YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF THIS TRAGEDY AND
INJUSTICE, AND COMMENDS THE
SECRETARY OF THE NAVY FOR
EXONERATING THE SAILORS
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED OF MUTINY
AND TAKING ACTION TO RESTORE
THEIR HONOR AND JUSTICE TO THE
SAILORS AND THEIR FAMILY.
UNFORTUNATELY AS WE STAND HERE
TODAY, NONE OF THE FAMILIES, OF
THESE SAILORS HAVE EVER BEEN
COMPENSATED OR THEIR BENEFITS
EVER RESTORED FOR THEIR FAMILIES
COULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE GI
BILL. BUT I STAND HERE TODAY
ASKING US TO REMEMBER THE
SACRIFICE AND ASK FOR OUR AYE
VOTE ON SR 110. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, SENATOR. SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLLCALL. ANY OBJECTION? AYES
36. NO ZERO. THE RESOLUTION
PASSES. MOVING.
I STAND CORRECTED, SENATOR
BRADFORD MOVES A CALL. WE HAVE.
ON FILE ITEM 45, WE ARE GOING TO
BE DOING A ROLL CALL. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE DALLI. AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LEHMAN MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. WHEN
AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA. BOG AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT. SENATOR BRADFORD
MOVES TO CALL. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING. WE HAVE
ONE ITEM FILE ITEM 150. SENATOR
WIENER, HE HAS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2867 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL. AN ACT RELATING
TO CIVIL ACTIONS AND DECLARING
THE URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
WIENER, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2867 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL, A BILL THAT WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS RECOVER ART
AND OTHER PERSONAL PROPERTY
STOLEN FROM THEM DURING THE
HOLOCAUST OR OTHER ACTS OF
PERSECUTION. AB 2867 BUILDS ON
PREVIOUS CALIFORNIA LAW TO AIM,
WHICH AIMS TO ASSIST CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS IN RECOVERING STOLEN
PROPERTY. UNFORTUNATELY, A
RECENT NINTH CIRCUIT COURT COURT
OF APPEALS DECISION FAILED A
FAMILY OF HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS,
THE CASSIRER FAMILY AND PROVES
THAT MORE MUST BE DONE TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS DON'T LOSE THEIR
RIGHTS DUE TO MISAPPLICATION OF
LEGAL TECHNICALITIES. IN THIS
CASE, CHOICE OF LAW, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BONTA AND
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL HARRIS
BOTH HAVE ARGUED THAT CALIFORNIA
LAW SHOULD APPLY TO CASES LIKE
THIS ONE. AB 2867 WILL DO JUST
THAT. IT WILL MANDATE THAT
CALIFORNIA LAW MUST APPLY IN
THESE LAWSUITS. AB 2867 HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION. IT'S SPONSORED BY
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
GROVE? THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I JUST OR EXCUSE ME,
MR. PRESIDENT. I JUST BRIEFLY
RISE IN SUPPORT OF, AB 2867 AND
THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE FLOOR
JOCKEY FOR BRINGING IT FORTH AS
FAR AS AS FAR AS THE, THE, THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IS
CONCERNED, THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL. AND, YOU KNOW,
I'VE OFTEN SHARED ON THIS FLOOR
THAT MY DAD WAS A WORLD WAR TWO,
MEDIC. AND HE WENT INTO
AUSCHWITZ AND BIRKENAU. AND, A
LOT OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
FOUND IN THESE CAMPS THAT
BELONGED TO THE JEWISH FAMILIES
THAT MAY NOT EVER GET RETURNED,
BUT FOR CALIFORNIA TO TAKE A
LEADING ROLE IN MAKING SURE THAT
THESE, SPECIAL MEMENTOS OR
PIECES OF ART OR FAMILY
BELONGINGS BE RETURNED TO THOSE
IN THE HOLOCAUST WOULD BE AN
EXTRAORDINARY EFFORT ON
CALIFORNIA'S PART AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM?
SEEING NO MICROPHONES, SENATOR
WIENER, YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR Þ.
ALL RIGHT. WELL, I'M ALL RIGHT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON. FINAL ITEM, 150 ALAN
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DELI. AYE DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I'M
IN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE WHEN? AYE
NEELO. AYE. OCHOA. BORG. AYE
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO.
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN GLAZER. AYE LIMON. AYE
MCGUIRE. UMBERG AYES 37 ON NØ
ZERO ON THE URGENCY. AYES 37.
NO. ZERO ON THE MEASURE. MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT CALLS ON THOSE
OUTSTANDING ITEMS. FIRST UP IS
FALL ITEM 28. PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS. ALLEN GROVE.
AYE MCGUIRE NGUYEN. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS UMBERG. AGE
36. NOES ZERO. AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN NOW MOVING ON TO
FALL. ITEM 45, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN GLAZER.
AYE. GROVE AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE.
UMBERG.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. ALLEN LEMON. AYE
MCGUIRE. UMBERG AGE 37. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. NOW IT'S TIME.
IF ANY MEMBER WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, WE WOULD ASK YOU TO DO
IT NOW. HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL
3057, 25, 73. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 159. ASSEMBLY BILL
453 672 1170, 1239, 1828, 1861,
1863, 1879, 1934, 2067 21, 1721,
30, 21, 43, 23, 24, 23, 50, 24,
22, 25, 67, 26, 31, 26, 36, 26,
37, 26, 92,929, 39, 29, 62, 29,
88, 29, 98, THREE, 30, OH SEVEN,
30, 62, 30, 83, 31, 16, 32, 35,
32, 78, 32, 90. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALAN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS I
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER I
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. CORTEZ
AYE. DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER.
AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO I. JONES. AYE LAIRD.
AYE. NYMAN AYE. MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILA AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
CABALLERO. AYE MCGUIRE. OCHOA
BORG. AYE UMBERG. AYES 37. NOES
ZERO. THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
APPROVED NOW. MEMBERS ARE
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. NOW IS THE TIME FOR
ADJOURN AND MEMORIES. WE HAVE
TWO ADJOURNMENTS. FIRST UP IS
SENATOR ATKINS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
REBECCA BECCA TAYLOR, CHAIR OF
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
PARTY. SHE DIED ON JULY 17TH,
2024, AT THE VERY YOUNG AGE OF
40. BECCA WAS BORN SEPTEMBER
10TH, 1983, IN IDAHO FALLS,
IDAHO, THE DAUGHTER OF TIMOTHY
JAMES AND PATRICE COOK. HER
FATHER WAS STUDYING IN THE NAVY
NUCLEAR POWER PROGRAM, AND HER
MOTHER WORKED IN THE HOME. WHILE
BECCA GREW UP A TRUE MILITARY
BRAT, SPENDING PARTS OF HER
CHILDHOOD IN MULTIPLE STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, INCLUDING
IDAHO, SOUTH CAROLINA, TEXAS,
CALIFORNIA, AND VIRGINIA, SHE
PREDOMINANTLY GREW UP IN TEXAS,
AND SHE WAS THE OLDEST OF SIX
SIBLINGS. SHE ATTENDED ALLEN
HIGH SCHOOL IN ALLEN, TEXAS AND
ENROLLED IN VIRGINIA TECH IN
2001. IN 2004, SHE JOINED THE
NAVY, WHERE SHE WORKED AS AN
AVIATION ELECTRICIAN. SHE WAS
DEPLOYED TO AFGHANISTAN AND
GERMANY DURING OPERATION
ENDURING FREEDOM. SHE SERVED AT
BRAHAM AIR FORCE AIRFIELD, WHERE
IN 2007, A SUICIDE ATTACK KILLED
NEARLY TWO DOZEN PEOPLE. AFTER
LEAVING THE MILITARY, SHE
ENROLLED IN SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY, WHERE SHE RECEIVED
THE OUTSTANDING UNDERGRADUATE
AWARD AT THE COLLEGE OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. IN 2009, SHE
EARNED HER BACHELOR OF ARTS IN
GERONTOLOGY. IN 2011, AND A
MASTERS OF SCIENCE IN
GERONTOLOGY IN 2013 FROM SAN
DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY. AS AN
UNDERGRADUATE, SHE ALSO STUDIED
ABROAD IN ENGLAND AND AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF OXFORD, TAKING
CLASSES IN POLITICAL SCIENCE.
HER PASSIONS INCLUDED HELPING
AND ADVOCATING FOR VETERANS,
SENIORS, SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS. SHE WAS ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN SOCIAL JUSTICE
CAUSES AND PROGRESSIVE POLITICS.
HER WORK WITH SENIORS INCLUDED
SERVING IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES AT
CASA DEL ORO, ADULT DAY HEALTH
CARE CENTER, THE SENIOR WELLNESS
PROGRAM AT BALBOA NAVAL
HOSPITAL, SERVING SENIORS IN SAN
DIEGO, THE ROSE OF POWAY, THE
BELMONT VILLAGE MEMORY CARE UNIT
IN POWAY, AND THE INDEPENDENT
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK OF
GREATER SAN DIEGO. SHE ALSO
VOLUNTEERED HER TIME AT THE SAN
DIEGO RAPID RESPONSE NETWORK'S
MIGRANT SHELTER, THE INTERFAITH
CENTER FOR WORKER JUSTICE OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY, THE CANNABIS
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, AND THE
OCEAN BEACH TOWN COUNCIL. I GOT
TO KNOW BECCA THROUGH HER
POLITICAL ADVOCACY, AND OF
COURSE, SHE WORKED AS A FIELD
ORGANIZER FOR NUMEROUS CAMPAIGNS
THROUGHOUT SAN DIEGO COUNTY, AND
ALSO AT HER TIME DURING HER
LEADERSHIP AT THE OCEAN BEACH
TOWN COUNCIL, SHE WAS A MEMBER
OF THE YOUNG DEMOCRATS OF
AMERICA, THE VETERANS CAUCUS OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
THE VETERANS DEMOCRATIC CLUB OF
SAN DIEGO, THE BLUE DREAM
DEMOCRATIC CLUB, THE POINT LOMA
AND OCEAN BEACH DEMOCRATS, AND
RUN WOMEN RUN. SHE BECAME ACTIVE
IN THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, SERVING AS
VICE CHAIR FOR THE METRO WEST
AREA BEFORE BECOMING COUNTY
PARTY CHAIR IN 2022. SHE
SKILLFULLY HELPED THE COUNTY
NAVIGATE THE COUNTY PARTY.
EXCUSE ME? NAVIGATE THROUGH SOME
VERY CHALLENGING ISSUES. BECCA'S
OTHER PASSION WAS RIDING HER
HARLEY DAVIDSON, INCLUDING ON
TRIPS ACROSS THE WESTERN STATES,
AND TRAGICALLY, HER LIFE WAS CUT
SHORT BY INJURIES FROM A
MOTORCYCLE ACCIDENT IN NEVADA
LAST MONTH. EVEN IN HER PASSING,
SHE CONTINUED TO HELP OTHERS
THROUGH ORGAN DONATION. BECCA IS
SURVIVED BY HER FATHER AND HER
STEPMOTHER, TIMOTHY AND AIMEE
COOK IN VIRGINIA. HER MOTHER AND
HER STEPFATHER, PATRICE, AND DON
FRAZIER IN PENNSYLVANIA. HER
SISTERS, BRANDI WATERS, HOLLY
EDWARDS, AND CAITLIN COOK. HER
BROTHERS, THOMAS COOK AND DYLAN
COOK, THREE NEPHEWS, TWO NIECES,
AND HER VERY LARGE EXTENDED
FAMILY OF FRIENDS AND
ASSOCIATES. BECCA WAS KNOWN FOR
HER PERPETUAL SMILE, HER
RELENTLESS ENERGY, STRATEGIC AND
DYNAMIC LEADERSHIP, HER ENDURING
OPTIMISM, IDEALISM AND DEVOTION.
SHE HAD AN INCREDIBLE IMPACT ON
THE SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY IN SO
MANY WAYS. MAY SHE REST IN PEACE
AND POWER. THANK YOU, SENATOR
PADILLA, ON THIS ADJOURNMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES, AND I
RISE TO ADD MY THOUGHTS AND
VOICE AS WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MY FRIEND BECCA TAYLOR.
SHE WAS A LEADER IN EVERY SENSE
OF THE WORD PRINCIPLED,
RELENTLESS, FIERCELY PASSIONATE
ABOUT ALL OF THE CAUSES THAT SHE
BELIEVED IN AND DEDICATED
HERSELF TO AND THAT'S BEEN NOTED
ESPECIALLY TO ISSUES DEALING
WITH SENIORS AND FELLOW
VETERANS. OTHERS HAVE MENTIONED
IT, BUT THE FIRST THING YOU
ALWAYS NOTICE ABOUT BECCA WAS
HER SMILE. IT WAS PERSISTENT. IT
WAS UPLIFTING. THERE WAS A POWER
TO HER PRESENCE, SOMETHING
EVERYONE COULD FEEL, A POSITIVE
ENERGY EVEN IN THE FACE OF
CHALLENGE. HER EXAMPLE WOULD
INSPIRE A ROOM AND OUR COMMUNITY
HAS A BRIGHTER FUTURE. THANKS TO
HER ADVOCACY. SHE WAS HUMBLE,
FUN, OPTIMISTIC, AND A FIERCE
ADVOCATE FOR HER COMMUNITY. HER
PARTY, AND HER COUNTRY. LIKE SO
MANY OF THE EXAMPLES SHE HAD SET
THROUGH HER ALL TOO SHORT LIFE
WHEN SHE WAS NEEDED, BECCA
STEPPED UP. I WAS VERY FORTUNATE
TO KNOW HER, TO WORK WITH HER
AND TO CALL HER MY FRIEND. HER
COMMITMENTS TO THE PEOPLE OF SAN
DIEGO, THE VALUES SHE CHAMPIONED
IN HER INNER LIGHT WILL BE
SORELY MISSED, BUT NEVER
FORGOTTEN. I CERTAINLY WILL
NEVER FORGET HER. REST IN POWER.
MY SISTER, COLLEAGUES, FOR THESE
AND ALL OTHER REASONS HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED. I ALSO ASK THAT THE
SENATE ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BLAKE, FOR.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
TODAY TO ADD MY VOICE TO THE TWO
GOOD SENATORS FROM SAN DIEGO IN
PAYING TRIBUTE TO BECCA TAYLOR.
SHE WAS THE CHAIR OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY PARTY AND DIED
TRAGICALLY IN AN ACCIDENT WHILE
RIDING HER BELOVED HARLEY
DAVIDSON MOTORCYCLE IN NEVADA ON
JULY 17TH AT THE AGE OF 40.
BECCA WAS A YOUNG, VIBRANT,
INTELLIGENT WOMAN WHO TRULY LIT
UP A ROOM WITH HER ENERGY AND
HER SMILE. I CAME TO KNOW HER AS
THE CHAIR OF THE SAN DIEGO PARTY
AND TO ADMIRE HER AS A WOMAN WHO
ROSE TO CHALLENGES WITH A CAN DO
ATTITUDE AND A PASSIONATE
COMMITMENT TO ADVOCATING FOR
CAUSES SHE BELIEVED IN AS A
YOUNG WOMAN, BECCA MOVED
FREQUENTLY AS THE ELDEST OF SIX
SIBLINGS IN A MILITARY FAMILY.
THIS MAY HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO HER
ABILITY TO ADAPT TO NEW
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THE CONFIDENCE
TO KNOW THAT SHE COULD SUCCEED
AT WHATEVER CHALLENGE CAME HER
WAY. SHE HAD NO TROUBLE
QUALIFYING FOR ADMISSION TO A
UNIVERSITY IN VIRGINIA, BUT WHEN
SHE REALIZED THAT SHE REALIZED
THAT SHE NEEDED MORE TIME TO
FIND HER PATH IN LIFE, SHE
JOINED THE NAVY. THE EXPERIENCE
OF BEING A YOUNG WOMAN AND
SERVING ABROAD IN AFGHANISTAN
AND GERMANY STRENGTHENED BECCA'S
UNDERSTANDING OF HERSELF AND HER
COMMITMENT TO LIVING A
MEANINGFUL LIFE. SHE ARRIVED IN
SAN DIEGO AS A YOUNG VETERAN,
DETERMINED TO FINISH HER
EDUCATION AND SET OUT ON A PATH
OF INDEPENDENCE. SHE DISCOVERED
AN AFFINITY FOR SERVING SENIORS,
WHICH INFLUENCED HER DECISION TO
GET HER MASTERS OF SCIENCE IN
GERONTOLOGY IN 2013 FROM SAN
DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY. BUT THE
REMARKABLE THING ABOUT BECCA WAS
THAT THERE WERE NO BOUNDS TO HER
DESIRE TO ENGAGE IN ACTIVITIES
THAT SHE BELIEVED IN, NOT JUST
TO DO A JOB. SHE WAS DEDICATED
TO MAKING THAT DIFFERENCE. THIS
LED HER TO WORK ON NUMEROUS
CAMPAIGNS FOR CANDIDATES WHO
SHARED HER VALUES AND
PRIORITIES. SHE TOOK ON
LEADERSHIP ROLES IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN SUPPORT OF
WOMEN VETERANS, AND THE LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITY. SHE SERVED ON
THE TOWN COUNCIL IN HER BELOVED
COMMUNITY OF OCEAN BEACH, WHERE
SHE WAS THRILLED TO PURCHASE HER
FIRST HOME. SHE WORKED WITH
REFUGEES AND VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT WITH THE SAME BIG
HEARTED COMPASSION THAT GUIDED
HER THROUGH LIFE, BECOMING THE
CHAIR OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AT A DIFFICULT
TIME. BECCA EXERTED CALM,
COMPETENT LEADERSHIP TO STEADY
THE SHIP AND SET A COURSE FOR
SUCCESS WITHOUT MISSING A BEAT,
SHE STEPPED INTO THE ROLES OF
SPOKESPERSON, MEETING, PRESIDER
AND FUNDRAISER. SHE STEERED THE
ORGANIZATION THROUGH COVID ZOOM
MEETINGS AND ANNUAL AWARDS
DINNERS. BECCA LIVED HER LIFE
WITH FLAIR, JOY, DETERMINATION
AND THE ABILITY TO GET ALONG
WITH LITERALLY EVERYONE. WE WILL
ALL MISS HER JOYOUS SPIRIT AND
REMEMBER HER AS A FRIEND, A
LEADER, AND A CONFIDENT YOUNG
WOMAN WHO LIVED HER LIFE TO THE
FULLEST. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO MISS
TAYLOR. WE ASK THAT YOU BRING
HER NAME FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. NEXT UP
IS SENATOR GONZALEZ FOR AN
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE HONOR OF
FORMER LONG BEACH CITY MANAGER
JERRY MILLER. BORN IN 1949,
MILLER MOVED WITH HIS FAMILY TO
LONG BEACH FROM SAN PEDRO IN
1961. HE SERVED IN THE ARMY
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR AND
GRADUATED FROM CAL STATE LONG
BEACH WITH DEGREES IN COMMUNITY
CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGY, AS WELL AS
PHILOSOPHY. MILLER WAS SWORN
INTO THE CITY'S TOP NON-ELECTED
POST IN 2003, AFTER EMERGING
FROM A FIELD OF 31 CANDIDATES
ACROSS 11 STATES, AND AS A
RESULT OF MILLER'S PERSEVERANCE,
THE CITY HAD COMPLETELY
REDEVELOPED THE NAVAL PROPERTY
AND FOSTERED A DOWNTOWN
REVITALIZATION. IN ADDITION,
MILLER LED THE CITY OUT OF THE
WORST FINANCIAL CRISIS TO DATE,
ENGAGING THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS,
BUSINESSES, AND EMPLOYEES IN A
PLAN DESIGNED TO ADDRESS A $100
MILLION BUDGET SHORTFALL. HE
RETIRED IN 2007 AFTER 35 YEARS
WITH THE CITY, BUT HE STILL
RECEIVED NUMEROUS AWARDS,
INCLUDING DISTINGUISHED ALUMNUS
AT CAL STATE LONG BEACH, A
DISTINGUISHED CITIZEN OF THE
YEAR AWARD WITH THE BOY SCOUTS,
THE FREEDOM FUND AWARD, ALONG
WITH THE NAACP, LONG BEACH
BRANCH AND THE PRESIDENT'S AWARD
FROM THE AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATION, AS WELL
AS MANY AWARDS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE,
GAYLE WASSEL, THEIR SON MICHAEL
MILLER, THEIR DAUGHTER ANNA
MILLER. MILLER'S BROTHERS, DAVID
AND KARL ZITTEL, AND MILLER'S
SISTER JOANNE DILLAHUNTY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. WE ASK THAT YOU BRING HER
NAME FORWARD, SO HIS NAME IS
FORWARD. I'M SORRY. SO HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. IF
THERE'S NO FURTHER BUSINESS. OH,
SENATOR LAMAR, I AM SO SORRY,
SENATOR LEMON. THANK YOU. I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
DOCTOR MARTIN SHAPIRO, KNOWN AS
MARTY BY FRIENDS AND FAMILIES.
MARTY PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY IN
HIS GOLETA HOME ON FEBRUARY
22ND, 20.
IF THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS,
SENATOR GROVE, THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. GREAT WORK
TODAY, COLLEAGUES. LOTS OF STUFF
THAT GOT OFF THIS FLOOR. AND I'M
SURE WE'LL BE HEADING TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK. THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THURSDAY, AUGUST 15TH, 2024 AT 9
A.M. I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
YOUR ALL HAPPY FACES ON
THURSDAY. MEMBERS. THE SENATE IS
ADJOURNED. WE'LL RECONVENE ON
THURSDAY, AUGUST 15TH AT 9 A.M.